Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao!
Aber ich werde das nicht machen!
M'uhemmm, m'uhm...
Was ist das...
Ich werde das nicht bitten totalmente,
weil da kommen wasADEOKU.
Und brightnessen.
שה
Baba...
So, jetzt bin ich relativ früh da, guck mal hier, es ist genau pünktlich 10 Uhr, auf
die Sekunde quasi, exellent. Los gucken, sounds, oh ne, ja stimmt alles, sehr gut, man weiß
ja, man weiß ja manchmal nicht, welche Software unter Windows wieder komische Dinge umstellt,
ne. Pause-Champ. So, ich glaube, jetzt kommt
langsam die ersten Leute, Twitch hat es gecheckt, dass der Stream online ist, das dauert ja
manchmal ein bisschen, ne. Das dauert ja manchmal ein bisschen, bis Twitch das kapiert hat.
Ich bin da gar nicht eingeloggt, null, 3D. Irgendwas dauert, boah, gute Frage, ja, eher
so, also bis Twitch die ganzen Notifications verschickt hat, eher, es kommt drauf an, so
von 2 bis 10 Minuten. Manchmal dauert es auch 10 Minuten, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass
der Stream on ist. Diesmal ging es anscheinend schneller, manchmal ist es nicht so klar, was
Twitch macht. Was ist das denn? Speed-Compassion für Past vs. Present, what the fuck. Moment,
das ist Print, das sind Browser. Hä? Warum vergleicht der Leute, die 100 Meter rennen
mit Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit im Webbrowser? Das ist merkwürdig. Fachinformatiker für
Systemintegration, ah, Excel, oh, da kriegt man erklärt, was man da macht, das ist bestimmt
wieder gerade zum Reingringen. Diese Titel immer, Battlefield 6 will be crazy if these
leaks are true. Ich kann mir auch ein paar Sachen ausdenken, liegt dran schreiben und
sagen, boah, das wird aber ganz verrückt, du wirst niemals erraten, was als nächstes
passiert. Zumal man ja auch nicht vergessen darf, dass viele der großen Battlefield Leute
da auf YouTube oftmals im Vorfeld schon relativ genau wissen, was Sache ist. Es kann mir keiner
erzählen, wer war denn so zu Battlefield 1-Zeiten voll angesagt, so Jack-Frags und
sowas, dass die das nicht wussten, das glaube ich nicht. Big Brain Video. Lul. Wird
man denn sonst noch so empfohlen? Four Dimensional, warum ist YouTube so scharf drauf, mir heute
irgendwelche komischen 4D, 5D, 6D, sonst was Sachen zu empfehlen. Die Titel, Alter. Corona
App, ich habe ja übrigens auch die Corona App am Start. Also nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwie
was bringen würde, weil ich gehe ja eh nicht raus, kennt mich ja. Wozu soll ich das eigentlich
installieren? Ich habe es doch gar nicht auf meinem Handy installiert. Zwischenbilanz,
okay, wie viel hat es schon gebracht? Ich will mir aber keine 10 Minuten Video angucken.
How NES Tetris Hardest World Record was? Moment, es gibt, okay, ich wollte gerade sagen,
es gibt Tetris Speedruns, aber es ist klar, dass es Tetris, wofür gibt es mittlerweile
nichts. Okay, ist langweilig. Die App geht bei mir auch nicht, Dr. Pro Noob X. Bei mir
geht die App auch nicht, weil ich habe ja eigentlich ein iPhone 6 und ein iPhone XS,
aber das XS hat keine SIM-Card, das heißt es bringt nichts. Ich habe es aber bei meiner
Mutter jetzt installiert auf dem iPhone SE. Das wird lustigerweise unterstützt. Ist ja
klar, das kriegt ja auch das neue iOS, hat auch das neue iOS gekriegt, weil es ein sehr
spitzes CPU ist. Also ich mich frage, ob iOS 14, ist das das neue? iOS 14 ist das neue?
Ob es das auch noch fürs iPhone SE geben wird? Guck mal, naja, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Ich weiß
nicht, wie vertrauenswürdig iphonesoft.fr ist. Wo ist eigentlich unser Baguette-Smiley?
Es hat doch letztens irgendjemand einen richtig coolen Baguette-Franzosen-Pepe gebastelt im...
Wo ist der hin? Das muss ich ja mal kurz suchen. Oh, Discord. Ach, ich muss gucken, dass ich
nicht im falschen Channel bin. MonkaS. Nicht, dass ich im falschen Channel bin. Nein, bin
ich nicht. Irgendeiner hat doch hier einen... Oder war das bei Emotes? Da darf man auf keinen
Fall rein jetzt. Wir hatten doch irgendwo einen Channel für Emotes. Da hat doch einer
richtig coolen French... Da, den brauchen wir. Exzellent. Okay, der ist zwar ein bisschen
klein, aber immerhin, ne, besser. Desktop. Jetzt kann man wieder zumachen. Was? Cancel?
Einfach, dass es funktioniert. So. Desktop. Oh, wie ist das Ding jetzt? Logo? Ja. Oh,
immer Logo. French. Ah, ja, exzellent. Jetzt haben wir auch noch Franzosen-Smiley, das muss
sein. Oh, darf man nicht rein? Das kann ich nicht zeigen im Stream. Da übernehme ich keine
Verantwortung für. Geht auf der Apple-Seite und der iOS-Profi. Okay, da muss ich mal kurz
rein. Ah ja, BigBrain-Ladezeit in die Seite. iPhone SE. Ach ja. Oh, das ist ja nice. Also
eins muss man Apple echt lassen. Die supporten ihren Scheiß, bis es nicht mehr geht. Warum
das iPhone 6 nicht mehr supportet? Wird es ja einfach, weil es ein 2-3-Split-CPU hat.
Das ist richtig gut hier, guckt's euch an. Wann kam das iPhone SE raus? Das ist jetzt
ja auch nicht mehr das allerneueste Gerät. Release Date. 2016. Da ist bei Android mit
Support vorbei. Es geht noch, es geht noch. Mein iPhone 6 ist älter. Wann war iPhone
6 Release Date? Okay, 2015. So ein großer Unterschied ist es gar nicht. Also vier, fünf
Jahre Support ist wirklich ordentlich. Und das spricht ja auch nichts dagegen, dass die
mit dem nächsten dann auch noch supportet werden. Das muss man Apple wirklich mal zugute
halten. Der Support für die Geräte ist wirklich gut. Auch von der Zeit her. Es gibt ja die
Leute, die dann sagen, ja okay, aber die machen ja absichtlich das dann langsamer auf alten
iPhones. Dazu kann ich nur sagen, mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn sie das machen würden.
Wobei ich glaube eher, dass es daran liegt, sie machen keine Optimierung mehr für die
alten. Ach, das war 6S. Ja. Ja, musst du dich überlegen. Also wenn das 2016 rausgekommen
ist, das erste iPhone SE und wann, keine Ahnung, iOS 14 wird dann bestimmt 2021 noch aktuell
sein. Also sprich, dann haben die das fünf Jahre Support. Da kannst du dich wirklich
nicht beschweren. Also da kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren. Und das neue iPhone SE ist
ja halt, das wird eh, das ist ja gerade erst rausgekommen, das wird auf jeden Fall noch
länger supporten. Ja. Also das muss man echt sagen, das macht Apple gut. Und da können
sich manche Android-Hersteller echt was von abschneiden. Ich hatte mir ja mal ein ASUS,
äh, Tablet, Android, was war denn das? Zeig mal her, was hab ich mir da gekauft? Ähm,
was ist das Ding? ZenPad, genau. Sowas hatte ich mir mal gekauft. Irgend sowas in der Richtung,
ZenPad, ähm, irgendwie sowas. Ich bin mir nicht mal ganz sicher, was das war, aber
sowas, sowas in der Richtung hatte ich mir mal gekauft von, von ASUS. Und der Witz war,
das hat nicht einmal, jetzt ohne Scheiß, ohne Spaß, Leute, ja, das hat nicht einmal
ein Update bekommen. Nicht einmal! Daraufhin hab ich mir gesagt, ich, äh, könne mich
mal. Es gibt doch leider kein Custom-ROM dafür. Da muss ich mal gucken, ob's jetzt
mittlerweile ein ordentliches Custom-ROM für gibt. Voll für'n Arsch. Ähm, deswegen kommen
mir nur Android-Tablets ins Haus, wo's entweder gescheite Custom-ROMs für gibt, die so billig
sind, dass es sich nicht, dass es nicht schadet, die alle nach einer Weile mal auszutauschen,
zum Beispiel wie Fire-Tablets. Und, äh, Tablets zum Benutzen, so die man wirklich tagtäglich
benutzen will, ist halt einfach ein iPad mittlerweile. Das haben sie halt verkackt. Da sind die Hersteller
selbst grad schuld. Ja, Jan a.k.a. Schwarzmaler, da geb ich dir recht. iPads sind, was Tablets
angeht, äh, bei Smartphones kann man sich dann auch streiten, je nach Anwendungszweck,
aber bei Tablets ist das, ist ein iPad das Beste. Die iPads sind jetzt ja auch nicht
so extrem teuer, wenn man sich überlegt, was ähnliche Android-Geräte kosten, ist
es auch kein großer Unterschied. Und der Support bei Apple ist halt einfach top, da kannst du
nix sagen, was, was Updates angeht. Oh. Und bei mir kann ja nur wirklich keiner sagen,
ich, ich, ich würde, ich hätte ein Seite hier, äh, Geräte, ja. Ich mein, ich hab
nen, ja, also, mal rechnen wir mal die Geräte zusammen hier. Also, ich hab nen, äh, wir,
wir, also wir haben nur ein iPhone SE, ein iPhone 6, ein iPhone XS, ein iPad, ähm, und
dann, keine Ahnung, nochmal 10 Android-Tablets, die sich so über die Jahre angesammelt haben.
Davon verwenden wir allerdings bloß, äh, zwei als Dashboard im Flur. Ich hab mein FireTV-Ding
deploated von Amazon. Ja, drei Stück verwenden wir davon. So, ok, aber trotzdem, äh, also
ich hab ja, ich hab ja alle Sachen in Benutzung und ich kann halt sagen, das hat alles seine
Vorteile. Ich hab, ich, ich hab schon, äh, ich hab schon so oft gesagt, ah die Musik,
du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du. Ä, exzellent, ja. Äh, wie gesagt, ich hab,
ich hab schon so oft gesagt, das hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung. Die Diskussion,
was besser ist, macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn. Man muss das nehmen, was am besten
funktioniert für das was man machen will und das ist bei Android wenn man irgendwas automatisch machen will oder wenn man
Irgendwas braucht was nicht so nicht so ganz standard ist oder default ist
Dann ist Android halt richtig gut wenn man zum beispiel will das automatisch wenn
Keine Ahnung ich möchte an das Tablet
einen HTTP-Request schicken und daraufhin soll dann automatisch der Bildschirm entsperrt werden und in den Browser
Gestartet werden mit der richtigen uhr das ist was vergisst es im vergess es im ipad
Vergess es bei ipad das kannst du komplett knicken das wirst du nie hinkriegen mit dem ipad gescheit
Enjoytablet ist das überhaupt kein problem
Also schau mal was haben wir denn für mich deswegen wir fangen mal an wir fangen mal ganz klassisch mit einem Battlefield top plays Video an
Das ist so happy happy musik
So auf geht's
Oh was von wann ist das Video vielleicht bin ich ja auch in der montage drinnen wie ich gebashed werden
Warum warum hat er warum hat er das game a high graphic settings?
Auf geht's
Vielleicht oder falls der hier passiert ist, dann kommt es nicht anyhow
Alle, andre
Die Tanks machen sich gar nichts mehr.
Was soll ich jetzt machen? Du siehst nichts?
Du siehst gar nichts!
Oh!
Lull!
Hahaha!
Die Gegner!
PP Gas, Alter!
BB Gas!
Hahaha!
In your face!
Oh, das war ein schöner Headshot eben!
Hä? Warum fällt der nicht um?
Moment, wie viel hat der Dude gerade ausgehalten?
Guck ich das mal an!
Der hat, der hat...
Was hat der denn alles ausgehalten gerade?
So, den Hit mit der Magnum.
Okay.
Drei Schuss mit der AN-94.
Hahaha!
Ben, viel Hitdetekt schneller!
Okay, das war mega Glück gerade,
dass der noch aus der Hüfte gehitet hat.
Das Ding habe ich nie gespielt.
Ich spiele eh nur M416.
Easy Mode Waffe.
Also die Musik im Hintergrund
ist schon ziemlich MonkaS.
Alter, der checkt ja mal gar nichts!
Wie kannst du da vorbeigeschießen?
Auf der anderen Seite,
es muss ja so sein.
Ohne Gegner, die braindead werden,
kriegst du das Ganze aus solchen Waffen.
Der war gerade, keine Ahnung,
Toaster, Toaster aus dem Toaster holen
oder sowas.
Direkt.
Ja.
Dreck runterschießen.
Ohoho!
Hey!
Der war letztens bei uns im Team.
Das ist so ein Bazaar
für die Spieler.
Das ist der, der den Panzer
die ganze Zeit in die Gegner gefahren hat,
als wir letztens gestreamt haben.
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Was zum...
Ey, das wird mich nicht wundern,
wenn ich da in dem Clip dabei wäre.
Guck mal, seht ihr mich irgendwo?
Weil ich hab mit dem auf Friend Bazaar
gespielt letztens.
Aber man sieht keine Kills.
Man hat ganz kurz das Scoreboard gesehen.
Wartet mal, das muss ich mir kurz angucken.
Nee, das war ja nicht das Scoreboard.
Das war der Spawnbildschirm.
Ah, okay, nee.
Ich wollte mich interessieren, ob ich in der Runde dabei war.
Scoreboard?
Was, echt, da war das Scoreboard drinne?
Nee, da ist kein Scoreboard.
Ich will wissen, ob ich in der Runde dabei war.
Wo ist Scoreboard?
Nein, sieht nicht so aus,
als war ich da dabei.
Oder vielleicht war ich auch zu schlecht
und bin gerade gejoint irgendwie da unten.
Aber der war letztens auch in den Games öfters drinne
und der ist so ein Grand Bazaar-only-Typ.
Den habe ich bisher nur auf Grand Bazaar-Maps gesehen.
Ah, Moment.
Nochmal.
Guck mal, ob da noch mal Scoreboard kommt jetzt.
Das wäre interessant, ob da ein Scoreboard kommt.
Nee, da kommt kein Scoreboard, ne?
Scoreboard?
Nein.
In dem Clip war kein Scoreboard drinne.
MonkaS!
Ich wollte gerade sagen, warum spielt er mit 30 FPS
das Game ruckelt ja.
Oder das Recording ruckelt.
Oh Gott, die Cake!
Erstmal eine Runde Sellout machen.
Easy Sellout, easy live.
Down below.
Diao Diggsos next.
Think that's how you pronounce your name.
Going in for another Metro Clip.
This time a big point stack on B-flag.
Ich müsste da auch mal irgendwas erspielen.
Voll auf irgendwie Streak spielen
oder sonst was.
Und da einschicken, weil mich würde echt
interessieren, wie der Informatiker ausspricht.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Informatiker.
Ein Informatiker.
Warum kriegt er 30 Milliarden Granaten Kills?
Wiederbeleben?
Nope, kein Bock.
Wann spielt er 4 zu 3 oder was ist das für ein Seitenverhältnis?
4 zu 3 in 2020.
Das könnte auch 16, keine Ahnung was das ist.
Nee, das ist gestaucht, das heißt es ist noch breiter.
Nee, das ist 16, 9.
Das ist 16 zu 9.
Nur, dass die das irgendwie gestaucht haben.
Das ist, wenn du das hier und das hier auseinander ziehst,
das ist exakt richtig.
Das ist ganz normal 16 zu 9, nur gestaucht.
Warum auch immer.
Auch immer.
Medvo.
Ich weiß nicht, wir müssen ja irgendwann mal in diesen Clips dabei sein,
weil es gibt irgendwie noch 3 aktive Server.
Ich guck die ganze Zeit oben rechts, ob ich irgendwo im Killfeed auftauche.
Oh.
Das ist aber schön hingelegt, dass er einfach nur in eine Richtung snipern kann.
Wie sie alle Farbenblindmodus anhaben.
Oh.
Baguette Clip.
Ich glaube, ich sollte die 1.94 auch abends mal ausprobieren.
Battlefield 3.
Das Ding schreddert sau schnell, wenn man trifft.
Also wenn man ppega-aimt, dann eher nicht.
Spaß.
Ja.
Das ist sau schwer.
Wenn es die Gegner gescheit machen,
wenn es die Gegner gescheit machen,
du kannst hier eigentlich nicht richtig durchkommen.
Du kommst mit dem LRV hier nicht rein.
Von vorne, egal.
Von vorne eh nicht.
Und wenn du dich hier oben auf die Kiste legst,
kannst du komplett reingucken und dich kaum keiner treffen.
Also gegen ein gescheites Team kannst du das so gut wie nicht einnehmen.
Zum Glück sind viele ppega-Teams unterwegs.
Die nicht mal checken,
wenn du direkt vor ihnen stehst.
Moin Knäherbär und der Kommentator.
Bin immer begeistert,
über welche Range die Shotguns
in Battlefield teilweise hitten.
Das ist halt total inkonsistent.
Mal ist One Hit über die halbe Map
und mal ist Two Shot direkt vor dir.
Oh, schon wieder.
Nee, das sind andere.
Das sind andere ppegas.
Vorhin hatten wir hier nochmal einen Clip.
Hä?
Seit wann ist er hier?
Ach, das ist Conquest.
Oh, da werden sie weggemäht.
Einfach mal nach hinten gucken, Leute.
Noshakennels.
Oh, das ist geil, wie sie nichts tanken.
Exzellent.
Collateral.
Alter, die Gegner.
Ist das gestellt?
Oder sind die einfach wirklich so brain dead, Alter?
Oh, mit Webcam.
Was ich echt cool finde, ist,
dass Battlefield 3 und vor allem Battlefield 4
seitdem es auf Steam ist,
mehr gespielt wird wieder.
Allerdings
ist halt die Steam Integration
scheiße.
Was?
Wegen dieser Kommentare habe ich Angst,
Shooter zu spielen. Hä?
Wie? Welcher hier? Chat oder was?
Chat, ich lese Chat nie.
Ist da ihre Shotgun Streaks?
Wenn ich das probiere,
wenn ich das probiere, werde ich immer direkt
One Shotted, weil meine Shotgun
nicht One Hitted.
Guckt euch mal die Range an.
Oh.
Deckt.
Und sicherlich, dass man das auch runtersprengen kann
mit dem Crossbow.
Exzellent.
Nice.
Und Battlefield never gets old.
Ah, Moment. Ne, das ist, das ist
normales Gameplay. Verstehe. Verstehe.
Ja, so was, so was,
so was kann ich dir immer gut angucken.
So, was haben wir hier als nächstes?
What the fuck?
Ok, Moment.
Warum ein Spiegel horizontal, aber nicht
vertikal spiegelt?
Oh, big brain time,
Leute. Big brain time.
Äh, warum?
Die Antwort ist,
glaube ich, ziemlich banal,
weil ein Spiegel gar nicht spiegelt, wie man sich das
vorstellt.
Also,
wenn Licht
in den Spiegel fällt, da wird es reflektiert.
Also ein Spiegel ist eigentlich kein Spiegel,
dass man links nach rechts und rechts nach
links spiegelt, wie in Photoshop oder so.
Sondern ein Spiegel reflektiert
einfach nur.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum
ein Spiegel horizontal,
Moment.
Aber ein Spiegel
spiegelt nicht spiegelt überhaupt, warte mal.
Moment, Spiegel.
Horizontal
spiegeln?
Hä?
Der spiegelt nicht
spiegelt nicht horizontal.
Oben bleibt oben, unten bleibt
unten.
Der spiegelt, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht, der Spiegel spiegelt nicht horizontal.
Der Spiegel
spiegelt, der reflektiert
einfach nur das Licht.
Wenn das horizontal spiegeln würde,
dann wäre
unten oben und oben
unten.
So, und wenn es vertikal
spiegeln würde, dann wäre
links rechts und rechts links.
Das ist aber nicht so.
Exposed. Ok, mal gucken, was
die erzählen.
Schäkel sagt
nein. Oi, Exposed.
Was ist mit dem Sprecher los?
Ja, genau.
Ich muss es ein bisschen lauter machen, glaube ich.
Excellent subscription.
Ja, genau.
Und das macht ein Spiegel nicht.
Beim Spiegel
ist oben oben und unten unten
und links links und rechts rechts.
Der reflektiert einfach nur das Licht, so wie es reinkommt.
Neuer Mod, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, der ist einfach
lange Zeit nicht da gewesen.
Kann das sein?
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Nein. Ach so.
Ja, Moment.
Moment.
Nee, macht er nicht.
Also ja, das macht er.
Moment.
Ja, Moment, aber das P ist immer noch rechts.
Da ist rechts und da ist das P rechts.
Oi.
Du bist stiller Zuschauer.
Warum bist du denn Mod?
Ich muss dich doch irgendwann mal aus irgendeinem Grund
gemoddet haben, Chuck96. Kann das
sein, dass das irgendwann war?
Ich versuche mich da gerade dran zu erinnern, wo keiner
der anderen Mods da war, wo ich gesagt habe,
hier wäre nicht schlecht, wenn wir noch einen Mod hätten.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Overwatch Zeit, ja, das kann sein.
Ich weiß nicht mal genau.
Ich, warte mal.
Das ist, das ist, der
vertauscht nicht links und rechts.
Der vertauscht nicht links und rechts,
weil guck mal.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das liegt einfach nur
da dran.
Ich glaube, das liegt einfach nur da dran.
Das, das, das, das sieht so aus.
Ich weiß, dass das
so aussieht in einem Spiegel.
Aber
das ist glaube ich,
das ist glaube ich Fail.
Was, man interpretiert da
glaube ich viel zu viel rein.
Weil rechts ist eindeutig rechts.
Also hier ist bei ihm das P
und da ist bei ihm das P.
Oder ist bei ihm das P da?
Ne.
Ne, ne, ne.
Also die rechte Hand
von ihm ist die rechte Hand hier.
Also wenn wir da jetzt quasi so als, als
bei ihm ist das P links?
Ne.
Nein, bei ihm kann das P nicht links sein.
Bei ihm ist das P hier.
Die rechte Hand, nein chat,
das stimmt nicht.
Die rechte Hand
hier bei dem ist das hier
im Spiegel.
Nein.
Chat, wenn ihr vor einem Spiegel
steht, wenn ihr jetzt,
also wir gucken da jetzt als dritte
Person drauf.
Das ist die rechte Hand
von ihm und auf der rechten
Seite im Spiegel ist seine rechte Hand.
Da wird nichts gespiegelt.
Ich glaube, dass man, dass man
mit der Schrift nicht klar
kommt, liegt da
dran, weil man das, weil man das nicht
gewöhnt ist, das so zu lesen.
Da spiegelt, spiegelt nichts
rein, also der spiegelt Spiegel nicht
wie Photoshop.
Letztens, ich hab letztens, na egal,
wir gucken jetzt einfach mal weiter.
Big Brain, Big Brain Time.
Genau.
Ja.
Siehste?
Genau.
Chat, was hab ich gesagt?
Hört's, hört's euch an.
Also stimmt der Titel auch gar nicht.
Genau.
Also quasi Z-Achse ist das dann,
oder?
Big Brain.
Ehrlich gesagt, mach ich das nicht unterbewusst.
Ja.
Sein Unterbewusstsein vielleicht nicht,
aber es gibt genug Leute,
da hab ich den ganzen Tag das Gefühl,
auf dem Kopf quasi, ja.
Big Brain.
Siehste, Chat?
Ich hat Recht.
Zumindest teilweise.
Also, wo ich jetzt,
wo ich echt am Chat
grade gezweifelt hab, ja.
Als der Chat ernsthaft behauptet hat,
dass, Moment,
dass,
dass die linke Hand von ihm
dort rechts rauskommen würde.
Da hab ich echt gedacht,
Low Brain Chat, ja.
Excellent.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Jetzt kennen wir uns aus.
Das hat niemand behauptet.
Soll ich jetzt, soll ich jetzt
hochscrollen, ja?
Nee, Moment, du hast das anders gemeint.
Du hast das gemeint aus der Sicht,
wenn du quasi der Typ im Spiegel wärst.
Das hab ich schon verstanden.
Ja, Moment, Moment, du hast es doch.
Moment, das ist die linke Hand des Spiegelbilders.
Richtig, richtig, ja.
Nee, die rechte Hand ist die linke Hand des Spiegelbilders.
Okay, dann hast du es richtig gemeint, wahrscheinlich.
Aber nur, wenn du quasi aus der Sicht
des virtuellen Typs
im Spiegel guckst.
Excellent.
Na gut.
Dann ist der Chat...
Dann ist der Chat doch nicht
Low Brain.
Aber Big Brain ist er auch gerade nicht.
Jack690, 11 Monate, Dankeschön.
Excellent.
Subscription.
Das ist ja 11 Monate,
ist ja fast schon links hier.
Wo hab ich mein Emote?
Okay, jetzt haben wir gelernt, was der Spiegel spiegelt.
Alles klar.
Jetzt sind wir schlauer.
Chat, also jetzt ist ja schon
auf dem Weg zu Sixhead.
Das sind wir.
Okay, wie geht's weiter?
Fachinformatiker...
Das ist cringe, Alter.
Ich will mir das gar nicht angucken.
Geh weg.
Wenn eine Atombombe deine Stadt trifft...
Ich bin wahrscheinlich tot.
Warum ist Pricing so...
Wenn die Videos nicht so Resident Sleeper wären...
Price... Dark Web Price Compassion.
Okay.
Das ist wieder so eine...
Das ist so ein
komplett an den Haaren herbeigezogenes
Ranking wahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Also...
Selbst wenn man das dort
kaufen kann,
hast du das Video von
das Video über Alexa gesehen?
Nee, schick mal einen Link.
Man kauft dort nicht...
Man beauftragt dort nicht jemand,
dass der
eine Netflix-Account hackt.
Das gibt einfach Leute, die haben jede Menge
Netflix-Accounts, davon kann man sich einen kaufen.
Wenn man das haben will.
Lifetime-Subscription-Spotify.
Ja, gut.
Solange...
dass dieser Account gebannt wird.
Ausweis. Ja, gut. Das wundert mich nicht.
Wenn was...
Control Panel
von der Webseite.
Man kann sich mehr als
10 Dollar kaufen. Warum nicht?
Social Media... So teuer ist Social Media...
Social Media-Account ist teurer als
Netflix-Account.
Warum das denn?
Wahrscheinlich weil die meisten
Two Factor Alternifizierungen haben.
Und es nicht so einfach geht.
Credit Card. Ja, das ist doch alles...
Credit Card.
Könnt ihr euch noch an das Video gucken, wo
auch dieser krasse
Möchtegern-Hackster da war,
der erzählt hat, dass er irgendwo
Kreditkarten, Kartendaten kauft und sie
dann in einer WhatsApp-Gruppe
weiterverkauft.
Das war Fail, Alter.
Über-Credentials.
Was mache ich damit dann?
Ich will ja nicht...
Da kann ich mir auch selbst anmelden
bei Über, wenn ich fahren will.
Was?
Man kann eine Schimpanse
für 50...
Müsste das nicht...
Ist das ein Livestream
von einem Schimpanse?
Oder ist es ein Alive,
also ein lebender
Schimpanse?
Also live mit F oder live mit
V?
Ich mein, Livestream von einem Schimpanse kann ich mir auch umsonst
angucken von irgendeinem Zoo.
Bulletproof Hosting Service.
Bulletproof Hosting Service,
sowas zu starten ist ja an sich nicht sonderlich schwer.
Wie bulletproof
das Ganze ist, entscheidet sich, wenn
mal die Polizei vor der Tür steht.
Also wenn jetzt irgendjemand,
sagen wir mal,
nach Sealand seinen Server
fliegen lässt, dann hat er auch...
Oder was gibt's denn da noch für
Venezuela oder sowas,
seine Server hosten lässt
und einfach jegliche Mails und
Sachen ignoriert,
die von der Polizei kommen, dann ist das
bulletproof. Die Frage ist nur,
wie bulletproof das ist, wenn die vor der Tür stehen.
Fake Driver License.
Brauche ich nicht.
Wozu brauche ich
eine Fake Driver Lizenz, wenn man doch
Bahn fahren kann?
Social Security Card.
Okay, das ist hier irgendein Kokona-Ding.
Was?
Was mache ich dann damit, wenn ich mir
eine Hand bestelle?
Dann habe ich eine Hand.
Und dann? Dann fängt
die an zu verwesen.
Und warum kostet die Hand genau
385 Dollar?
Ein Fuß.
500 Dollar.
Also, mich würde nicht
wundern, wenn man das wirklich
ohne Probleme bestellen könnte.
Ist es überhaupt verboten,
Füße zu bestellen?
Jetzt mal rein theoretisch, ist es verboten,
sich einen menschlichen Fuß
zu bestellen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, ob das
verboten ist.
Ich meine, du hast den Typ ja nicht
umgebracht oder so.
Vielleicht ist das aus irgendeinem Kriegsgebiet.
Der ist auf eine
Mine getreten und der Fuß ist weggeflogen.
Und dann haben die den Fuß
verpackt und im
Dark Knight angeboten. Und dann
hat man den Fuß.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich, ob das
illegal ist.
Ist eine gute Frage.
Also, Scam Tutorials,
die muss man nicht
im Dark Web kaufen.
Scam Tutorials kann man sich einfach mal
bei den Indern abgucken.
Wir sind ja die Scam
Kings, was das angeht.
Zwar so schlecht zum größten
Teil, dass es wieder richtig lustig ist.
Und außerdem, ich weiß nicht, ob man ein Tutorial
braucht dafür.
Oder im Chat, genau.
Ein US Password braucht
dann sowas.
Moment.
Man kann sich Augen bestellen,
die funktionieren. Aber
wie funktionieren die denn?
Also, wie funktionieren die denn, wenn die
in der Kiste ankommen?
Oder meinen die damit,
jemand läuft mit einer Webcam
durch die Gegend?
Oder ist das so Wahrsager-Kugel-mäßig?
PayPal-Account.
Das halte ich jetzt
für einen...
Also, du kannst
wahrscheinlich die PayPal-Accounts, wo 12.000
Euro auf 12.000 Dollar aufgeladen sind,
vielleicht nicht
an einer Hand abzählen, aber
so viele wird es da nicht geben.
Weil, warum sollte man seinen PayPal-Account
mit 12.000 Dollar aufgeladen haben?
Exploit Kids.
Warum eigentlich nur US Passports?
Was interessieren mich US Passports? Ich will da eh nicht hin.
Okay.
Schläger-Truppe.
Was nennt Tiger
Baby?
What the fuck?
Das ist Schwachsinn, Alter.
Eis, Bär,
Fell...
So kostet also ein Auftragskiller.
Das haben die natürlich
überprüft, mit Sicherheit.
Gefälschte Bandnoten.
Moment, gefälschte Bandnoten
sind teurer als ein Auftragskiller?
Ich kann mir gefälschte
Bandnoten doch selbst ausdrucken und einen Auftragskiller nicht?
Jebaited, das kann nicht sein.
Das ist fake.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass
man das gar nicht darf?
Geldscheine ausdrucken.
Es gibt eine Funktion in Druckern,
wenn die erkennen, oder in Scannern,
wenn die erkennen, dass du Geldscheine scannen und drucken willst,
dann funktionieren sie nicht.
Das habe ich mir jetzt nicht ausgedacht.
Das darf man nicht.
Und manche Drucker
drucken halt auch nicht.
Was?
Warum ist jemandem das
Beinbrechen teurer als der Auftragskiller?
Na gut, okay,
kann ich mir vorstellen,
der Auftragskiller
der muss sich ja nur
360 Sniper Scope ans Fenster setzen.
Und
wenn der dem das Bein brechen will,
muss er ihn anfahren oder sowas.
Das Video ist absolut trap, kann das sein?
Ja, es ist totaler Müll.
Ein Kopf?
Ein Elefant?
Okay, okay, okay, okay,
das muss Troll sein.
Das muss ein Trollenvideo sein.
Ganz im Ernst.
Wie willst du den Elefant bestellen?
Das ist ein bisschen auffällig.
Moment.
Warum kostet das Ermorden
45.000?
Und der Auftragskiller
kostet nur 10.000?
Du musst doch immer den Auftragskiller nehmen.
Guck mal, für den Preis
von einem Mord kannst du
4 Auftragsmorde dir kaufen
im Dark Web.
Oder ist das
das eine der AliExpress Killer und das hier
der Qualitätskiller?
Der Auftragskiller macht nur One Hit.
Ja, One Hit reicht ja auch.
One Hit.
Sniper in your face.
Ein Tiger.
Disappear.
Das ist Spaß ins Video, Alter.
Hitmarker macht er.
Ein Leber.
Okay, das kann man doch
einfacher haben.
Guck mal,
da könnte man direkt
ein Geschäft draus machen.
Guck mal, wenn es 100.000 Leber
und 200.000 Herz kostet.
Dann
buchst du dir einfach Auftragskiller
für 10.000.
Lässt die Leute Auftragskillern.
Dann nimmst du dir das Leber und das Herz
und verkaufst das wieder.
Selbst wenn nur die Hälfte klappt,
kannst du
quasi
du machst immer noch
viermal mehr, fünfmal mehr
Geld, selbst wenn die Hälfte
in die Hose geht,
von Leber und Herz, wenn du den Auftragskiller
bezahlst.
Ne, zehnmal mehr Geld.
Was?
Das hat jetzt so lange gedauert, was?
Was ist Beerball?
Galle.
Was so?
Beeren.
Wollt man sich sowas denn kaufen?
Oh guck mal Harambe
Ein Attack Gorilla
Ok das muss Troll sein
Einmal Harambe bitteschön in meinem Hof
Also Entfucken Wahrheit ist ja an allem dran
Aber das weiße dürft ihr kompletter Blödsinn sein
Angeblich heilende Wirkung
Ja das ist wie wenn sie irgendwelche Nashorn Hörner für die Potenz haben und sowas bescheuertes
Was schaut ihr mal zum Thema Fake Geld an?
Heute Morgen bezahlt ein Mann im Lebensmittel Discounter mit falschen 50€ schon mal
Eben scheint es sich um Spielgeld beziehungsweise Movie Money
Ohja gut, probieren kann man es ja
Da steht sogar Prop drauf, ernsthaft?
Das hab ich gar nicht gesehen
Prop Copy
Ok das hätte ich aber echt nicht gesehen jetzt
Das hätte ich jetzt wirklich auf die Schnelle nicht gesehen
Und ich glaube die Kasiererin sieht das auf die Schnelle auch nicht
So was sollte ich mir oben eben noch angucken?
Irgendeiner hat einen Link gepostet
Ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das angucken will, Zeit mal
Vielleicht später
Ups
Alexa
Ok wenigstens kriegen wir dann mal was für unsere Gebühren
Wie oft Smart Speaker heimlich mittern?
Das ist so viel zu lang, 21, also 21 Minuten
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, also ohne dass ich mir das Video jetzt angeguckt habe
Also das ist der Grund warum ich mir keine Alexa Sachen hinstelle
Weil es kam ja schon in der Vergangenheit raus, dass Sachen aufgezeichnet werden
Ich glaube nicht nur bei Alexa, ich glaube auch bei Google und im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich
auch bei Cortana und sowas ausgewertet wurden
Also quasi was Leute sich angehört haben, angeblich um den Service zu verbessern und
sowas
Also das ist jetzt nichts Neues an sich
Was haben wir als nächstes, Price, das haben wir uns gerade angeguckt
MW3 Moab with every gun
Ich weiß nicht warum ich das Video offen habe, aber der macht immer gute Videos
Das haben wir sonst noch zu bieten
Best Battlefield to date, Minecraft Raytracing, ne das kommt man uns nicht an, das ist doof
How thermal compounds, warum, ich manchmal weiß ich nicht genau warum ich Videos aufgemacht
habe
Ah yes, excellent, Wärmeleitpaste
Und das jetzt zweieinhalb Minuten oder was
Also das ist für alle die Hardware, also gerne Hardware Sachen bauen, ist das natürlich
Meditationsmaterial
Weil das Video ist von 2009 und 4 zu 3
Da das geht nicht richtig
Fester drücken
Der Typ kann gar nicht so fest drücken wie er das anziehen würde mit Schrauben
By the way seht ihr das Oldschool Mainboard von 2009
Das ist richtig Oldschool
Line Method
Boah was ist das für ein riesen Pappen, Haufen
Jetzt gleich hier
Excellent, ja man erkennt das es von 2009 ist weil es keine RGB Beleuchtung gibt
Ja richtig
Sieht aus wie frisch gehts ja
Und Philadelphia
Sieht echt ein bisschen so aus
Sieht fast aus wie so ein Regenwurm worauf er vorher drauf gedreht hat er so aus Versehen
Das ist echt ein bisschen so aus Versehen
Sieht aus wie so ein Regenwurm worauf er vorher drauf gedreht hat er so aus Versehen
Was denn das hat das jetzt vorher komplett verteilt oder wie
Wo ist das X
Cross Method
Beste
So macht man es
Vielleicht ein bisschen schöneres X aber so macht man es
Jawoll genau so gehts
Einfach ein X drauf
Beste
Vielleicht nicht ganz so viel und ein bisschen dünner und ein bisschen länger an manchen
Stellen
Aber ja prinzipiell so macht man es
X ist beste
Also wenn man das fest drauf drückt
Ansonsten es spricht auch überhaupt nichts dagegen die Wärmeleitpaste so ein bisschen
drauf zu verschmieren dass es alles schon bedeckt ist
Bloß in der Regel braucht man weniger Wärmeleitpaste als man denkt
Ich hab früher auch immer richtig viel drauf geschmissen
Teilweise so viel das das Leben rausgelaufen ist
Es reicht eigentlich ein kleiner Klecks
Haben wir ein Netz hier noch schon
Lego Self Erecting Mobile Crane
Alles klar
Wow was geht da ab
Fachinformatiker Video
Ok wir gucken es danach
Aber das ist bestimmt wieder so richtig cringe
Was ist das da eigentlich
Krissbaumkugel ist das der Krissbaumkugel
Das sieht aber ziemlich komplex aus
Das ist
Big Brain
Jetzt wo ich das gerade im Hintergrund gesehen hab
Da hat er hier die Stadt im Hintergrund
Wusstet ihr dass diese Szene aus Matrix wo die mit dem Helikopter vor den
Also da wo sie Morpheus gefangen haben
Wo die mit dem Helikopter vor das Fenster fliegen
Und mit der Minigun das ganze Büro zerschießen
Dass der Hintergrund ein Plakat ist
Das hab ich mal in irgendeinem Matrix Making of gesehen
Das ist gar keine echte Stadt
Das ist einfach das größte Plakat von der Stadt was hier gebaut wurde
Generell ist am Matrix noch sau viel Handmade
Boah das ist ne richtig massive Brain Konstruktion
Boah ey
Also die Konstruktion ist irgendwie so gebaut
Dass ich mir vorstellen könnte mit richtigem Material und richtigen Sachen
Würde das auch richtig funktionieren
Guck mir wie gut das ineinander passt
Hört euch das mal an High IQ Lego Builds
One Punch Flash Moin
Das funktioniert richtig gut guck mal
Der baut sich selbst zusammen der Kran
Richtig Pro
Das ist ja mal geil
Hätte ich früher genug Lego Technik Teile gehabt
Hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch so Dinger gebaut
Also ich hab ja früher auch den ganzen Tag Lego Technik Zeug gebastelt
Sowas hätt ich damals auch gerne gebaut
Ich glaube ich hätt es nicht hingekriegt
Aber sowas hätt ich damals sicherlich gerne gebaut
Das ging ein bisschen in die Hose
Aber guck mal wie hoch das ist
Das ist bestimmt schon so ein Meter hoch
Ah guck mal sogar mehr
Sogar mehr
1,40 hoch
Zum Glück hat es in Zentimeter dahinter geschrieben
Weil 55 Inch ist
Das ist bei Matrix echt ein Poster
Also die Szene in Matrix, die ich meine ist, dass
Neo Rescue Smorphor ist
Also Spoiler Spoiler
Also wer Matrix euch gesehen hat
Das ist von 1999
Das hier ist ein Plakat
Nee
Wo ist das mit dem Heli
Das hier
Das hier im Hintergrund ist ein Plakat
Die Stadt im Hintergrund
Hier sieht man es gut
Die Stadt im Hintergrund ist ein Plakat
Das ist keine echte Stadt
Das haben sie alles im Studio aufgebaut
Und wenn man das weiß
Ein bisschen erkennbar ist auch
Auch von der Beleuchtung her und so
Weil die ist schon sehr einheitlich alles
Da wird halt einfach dran gestrahlt
Das ist ein Plakat
Das fällt im Film nicht auf
Das war zum damaligen Zeit
Ich hab vor Urzeit mal ein Making-of gesehen
Das hab ich mir irgendwie gemerkt
Das ist oder war zumindest das größte Stadtplakat
Was je für ein Film gebaut wurde
Und auch der Regen war
Ich guck wenig Making-ofs
Aber das Matrix-Making-of
Hab ich damals geguckt
Das war echt interessant
Auch wie die das mit dem Regen gemacht haben
Die hatten nämlich das Problem
Dass die konnten diese Szene bloß 20 Sekunden aufnehmen
Weil das Wasser sonst da rausgelaufen ist
Und das Equipment nass gemacht hat
Also das war nicht ohne das Ding zu drehen
Und Matrix ist ja fast ohne CGI entstanden
Also ja es gibt CGI
Die Flugszenen mit dem Raumschiff sind CGI und sowas
Aber 1999 war so ne Zeit
Da ist noch ziemlich viel Special Effects
Special Effects ohne CGI gewesen
Also Matrix hat relativ wenig CGI
Was haben wir denn hier
Google Data Center Security
Six Layers Deep
Excellent
Warum keine Acht
Oder 69 oder so
Das ist ein Google Werbefilm
Darf man nicht vergessen
Das muss ich wegmachen
Ich war echt gebannt
Ist das die VR-Google-Class-Frau
Die sieht ja irgendwie ähnlich
Ist das die Google-Google-Class-Frau
Nee das ist nicht die Google-Class-Frau
Die Google-Class-Frau ist die, mit der der eine Gründer fremdgegangen ist
Und wo vermutet wurde, dass Google-Class quasi nur aus diesem Grund überhaupt rausgekommen
ist
Wie heißen die
Google-Class
Glasses
Wie hießen das
Google-Class
Frau
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie die hieß
Wie hieß die
Manager
Hier, Amanda Rosenberg, genau
Die war das
Das ist schon ein echt hottes Grill muss man sagen
Das ist die Google-Class-Frau gewesen
Nee das ist jemand anderes
Das ist jemand anderes
Die ist auch nicht mal bei Google
Vermute ich mal stark nach der ganzen Google-Class-Geschichte
Muss man seine Daten nicht vor Google selbst schützen
Je nachdem, was man preisgeben will, schon
Ich glaube
Es wird erst mal erschossen, wenn du da einfach ohne Genehmigung in die Nähe fährst
Oder zumindest getasert
Und weil das die USA jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich von irgendeiner Artillerie weggeknallt
Oder was heißt von der Artillerie weggeknallt
Da kommt die Predator-Trone und schießt ihr eine Rakete auf den Kopf
Exzellent
Also muss man sagen, Wachpersonal und Kameras haben sie alle
Aber mal gucken, was Google noch mehr hat
Okay, das haben nicht alle
Also früher hat man sowas mit Stacheldraht gemacht
Das hat wahrscheinlich auch funktioniert
Aber Stacheldraht ist nicht stylisch und fancy genug dafür
Oh, AC130
Das ist ganz einfach, wenn du deine Karte verlierst, kommst du nie wieder raus
Wenigstens ist es andere als seine Karte nicht zu verlieren
Ja, das ist normal
Das haben sie im Dezix auch
Im Dezix sind es so kleine Röhren, wo du rein musst
Vor allem wenn du einen Server dabei hast, ist das ganz schön eng
Aber das funktioniert doch auch nur, wenn die Leute mitmachen wollen, oder?
Wenn es einer darauf anlegt, das nicht einzuhalten, dann muss er es nicht einzuhalten
Ja, das haben die meisten auch
Weißt du was ich mich gerade frage?
Ich kenne ja das Werbevideo, was sie bei uns auf, was sie bei uns gedreht haben
Was ich mich gerade frage ist, ich habe ja schon erzählt, bei uns haben die auch mal
so ein Werbevideo gedreht von unserem Support und haben dann für das Video extra noch Leute
reingesetzt, die da normalerweise nicht setzen
Also unser Werbevideo für den Support hätte halt normalerweise nur junge bis mittelalte
weiße Männer gezeigt und für das Werbevideo haben sie halt noch Frauen reingesetzt, noch
Schwarze reingesetzt, noch eine Frau mit einem Kopftuch reingesetzt, dass das halt möglichst
divers ausgesehen hat
Und ich frage mich gerade, ist das in diesem Werbevideo auch so?
Weil wie gesagt, in unserem Werbevideo war das so
Ja wozu auch, die meisten wollen nicht, ich bin auch froh, dass ich gar nicht mehr ins
Rechenzentrum muss
Mit so Wagen ist auch relativ normal
Und die, und die, gehören wahrscheinlich gar nicht zu Google, sondern arbeiten bei
irgendeiner Fremd-Tochterfirma was auch immer und verdienen den Appel und ein Ei
und
Are erased and destroyed and the fewest number of people are allowed to enter drives that need to be retarded
in strettung halb
secure to a locker system which means that only
Technicians assigned to this room can pull them from that locker to either erase or destroy so ifa schlüssel ist doch scheiß egal
Moment also also sprich
wenn da jetzt eine festplatte reinkommt
das heißt da kommen auch manchmal festplatten rein die nicht die nicht destroyed werden oder wie
ist halt ein schredder
was ist das eigentlich für ein strichmännchen
das ist doch nicht mal p-pro-fed das ist irgendwas mit außergewöhnlich langen
bein und und ziemlich viel bauch das in kombination wird eher dazu führen dass das bein durchbricht
slenderman das hat wirklich was davon
ja wirst gewogen
also ist ja was also was man daran an dem video schön sieht
ich meine sie wollen uns ja damit sagen dass sie die geilsten sind google kocht auch nur
mit wasser das ist ziemlich normal was sie da gezeigt haben
halt nur mit budget also sprich sowohl sowohl von von von zollen von überwachungskameras
von security personal von von einem monitoring team von festplatten schredder bis sonst was
das ist ziemlich das ist ziemlich standard also ist jetzt nicht so als wird das nur google
machen oder so google hat halt budget das sieht man dem ganzen ding an ja also das ist mit
sicherheit qualitativ schon besser ausgeführt als beim feldwald und wiesen location colocation
anbieter oder so aber im prinzip kochen die auch nur mit wasser da ist jetzt nichts revolutionäres
einzigartiges dabei
hat
maxi häufig in der woche kreinest du amazon warum sollte ich amazon kreinen du meinst
was interessiert ja einmal am tag mal ich da aufgucken durch moment das das verwirrt
mich jetzt gerade das verwirrt mich noch mehr als der spiegel vorhin gut das ist letztendlich
unter unter der haube ist das halt gefegt beim render man wie soll sonst funktionieren
kannst du es lauter machen haben wir das nicht schon mal gesehen weiß nicht kann mir nicht
dran erinnern oder big brain
ich habe es nicht kapiert low brain habt ihr es verstanden
moment moment moment moment rechts ist grün und da ist auch grün
moment das ist viereckig aber es ist dreieckig innen drinnen
das ist so das ist so viel für mein hier na
ich hab ich hab es auch nicht gecheckt auf beim ersten mal sehen hier
das kenne ich das kenne ich wenn ich in meinem schrank wo ich sachen für die steuererklärung
drinnen liegen hab sachen suche dann ist das auch so
ah die gute alte der gute alte teepot kann man beides man kann beides sehen ok
notice how you can see both objects at once
und enden auf dem Top
Aha
Es ist auch ein Beispiel deiner Großvateres Geschichten
um auf dem Topf zu gehen
Er lebte in einem non-Euclideanen Plan der Existenz
und dann hochlaufen, und dann wieder hochlaufen, und dann wieder hochlaufen
Gut sowas ist einfach zu faken
Still not small enough to get through
But if I go around one more time
I can go the other way around too to keep getting bigger
But eventually I won't be able to fit into the tunnel anymore
So how does all this work?
Well it's basically the same as the game Portal
But the Portals have no seams
And there's often more than two of them
There are several surfaces that are actually solid geometry
It's just that I draw a texture on top of it
That's actually a virtual camera rendering
What it would have seen from that perspective
And when you walk through it
It teleports you seamlessly to where you're supposed to end up
The rendering is a lot harder than it sounds though
Each surface has to recursively render surfaces behind it
Conditionally, depending on if it's occluded or not
From each perspective
I originally was trying to do this
In Unity
But I'm pretty sure it's impossible
Without lower level access to the rendering
Even the scriptable pipeline didn't work for me
So I was forced to create my own rendering engine
In OpenGL
Why do I keep writing engines?
Anyway
The last thing I wanted to talk about
Are the use cases
Other than just for puzzle games
This is actually incredibly useful for virtual reality
You see, normally for room scale VR
You're limited to a small area to walk around in
You can't really explore a larger open world
Without breaking the illusion
Like teleporting
But this engine can compress entire levels
To fit into a single room
Here I have a single 20ft by 20ft room
That you can walk around in and explore
But it actually contains a volume
Four times larger
And although I haven't actually tested this in VR
It looks like a Half-Life 1 level
That a beginner in WorldCraft made
Wow
Okay, that makes me really...
That confuses me
That looks original like Half-Life 1 textures
Aha
Okay
That would actually be something really good
For any horror games, right?
Because
Because most horror games
Are based on the assumption
That the player doesn't expect what's going to happen
Or that what...
No, not only that
That what's going to happen doesn't happen
And that what's going to happen
Doesn't seem believable
That's why
In horror games there are often people
Who have long arms
Or long legs
Or something that doesn't look natural
That's just
That's a bit brainfucked
Excellent
Where did a desktop PC go?
Oh, that's BigBrain
RL
Crafting
Now I'm learning computer science
Okay, okay, okay
That's probably really boring and bad
And
And cringy
Karriere
Bei Wirth Electronics
Elektronik
More than
You expect
Ich würde expecten, dass eure Schrift
Auf das Video passt
Mein Name ist Michael, ich bin
21 Jahre alt
Ist das Michael 50 Billion?
Ich bin Christian Reichmund und ich lerne Fachinformatik
Für Systemintegration
Meine Aufgabe hier ist, gemeinsam mit unserem Team
Zu sorgen, dass die IT im gesamten Unternehmen
Funktioniert
Am Anfang der Ausbildung macht man einen einmonatigen Betriebsdurchlauf
Richtig ordentliches Patch-Panel
Und die Fertigung, um zu lernen, wie die Leiterplatte hergestellt wird
Anschließend kommt man
In die eigene Abteilung, wo man verschiedene
Aufgabenteile bearbeiten kann
Und verschiedene Bereiche kennenlernt
Wie z.B. ein User-Help-Desk
Und dann auch die alltäglichen Probleme des Users kennenlernen kann
IGIT User-Help-Desk
Monks
Reptile Hunter 8 Monat, Dankeschön
Big Brain Sub
Für den Ausbildungsberuf braucht man keine besonderen
Vorkenntnisse, allerdings sollte man schon
Eine gewisse Affinität
Was haben die da für uralt-antike
Dinger drin? 72,8
GB
OlaHP Server, das ist ein richtig
Alter, das ist irgendwie ein DL380
Gen, frag mich nicht, Gen
5 oder so, das ist
Richtig alt
Das ist so einer
Gen, Gen, keine Ahnung,
Gen 6 oder so
Ja, guckt hier, so einer ist das
Ok, vielleicht nicht
Gen 5 soll ich sagen
Gen 7
Ja, sowas in der
Richtung, eher Gen 6
Bestimmten ist fürs Video
reingehauen
Übrigens, wo man sich generell bei Servern
im Rechenzentrum nicht so sehr dadurch verwirren
lassen darf, ist, dass da vorne
ein VGA-Port dran ist
Die sind noch nicht bei HDMI
oder gar Display-Port angekommen
Jetzt gerade
fängt das
an, dass die Server
was anderes als VGA haben
Aber selbst jetzt
hat fast jeder Server, also ich kenne keinen Server
der nicht VGA hat
Nicht zumindest nicht noch zusätzlich
Ja, es fängt jetzt
gerade erst an
Die brauchen halt immer ein bisschen 20 Jahre, 20 Jahre
15 Jahre länger
Was ist das für ein DVD-Laufwerk
Naja, ein DVD-Laufwerk halt
Was ist das DVD-Laufwerk
Zum Beispiel, dass du Sachen drauf installieren kannst
Die meisten machen das
bei USB-Stick
Wenn man überhaupt noch
rüber muss vom USB-Stick
Ansonsten ist das ganze Netzwerk gut
Man sollte wissen
welche Hardware in einem Computer steckt
wenn es um Programmiersprachen geht
Man muss sie nicht können
Aber man sollte schon wissen, für was sie gut sind
Natürlich sollte man Programmiersprachen können
In meiner Ausbildung sind die Hauptaufgaben
zum Beispiel der User-Helpedesk
Dazu gehört nicht das Helfen von Benutzern am Telefon
bei Problemen sind auch das Einrichten
und Konfigurieren von Rechnern und Ausstellungen
oder auch die Schubesebene dabei
End-User-Support, Bonkays
Bei neuer Hardware
Ich durfte hier schon früh sehr viel Verantwortung übernehmen
Ich habe verschiedene Projekte
Darf neuen Mitarbeitern IT-Schulen geben
Und habe auch sonst nicht mehr meine eigenen Verantwortung
Darf außerdem an IT-Meetings teilnehmen
Und das gefällt mir sehr
In der Schule...
Es gefallen IT-Meetings
Was ist das?
Die haben doch vorher
sich einen Text aufgeschrieben
oder einen Text vorgeschrieben bekommen
Was sie sagen sollen
Niemand mag Meetings
Zumindest nicht sinnlose Kreisel-Meetings
Und zum Beispiel
wie das Netzwerk theoretisch aufgebaut ist
Ja, das stimmt
Wie die einzelnen Komponenten funktionieren
Ich bin unter anderem zuständig
für die Videokonferenzanlagen
Wenn in irgendeinem Standort von unserem Unternehmen eine gebraucht wird
Dann landet die vorher bei mir
Ich konfiguriere sie
Das heißt, ich nehme sie in die Domäne auf
Ich schaue, dass die Videokualität stimmt
Deswegen müssen wir bestimmte Bandbreiteneinstellungen vornehmen
Und dann, wenn alles fertig ist
wird das Ding wieder losgeschickt
Eigentlich mag ich alles besonders gerne da
Es auch jeden Tag wechselt
Und man sich direkt darauf vorbereiten kann, was als nächstes passiert
Ein Highlight meiner Ausbildung war
Ich persönlich finde es immer doof, wenn ich mich nicht abschätzen kann
Weil es als nächstes passiert
Ich finde es ganz gerne, was so auf mich zukommt
Aus Geschmackssache
Wir haben dort einen Standort umgezogen
Ihhh
Wer will denn sowas machen?
Wir haben dort einen Standort umgezogen
Also, wer möchte nach Holland um den Standort umzuziehen?
Ich will morgens auf die Arbeit gehen
Ich will meine Arbeit machen
Und ich will heimgehen, Streamern machen
Pass of Exile spielen, YouTube Videos machen
Was auch immer
Aber ich will nicht 3 Wochen in Holland rumgammeln
Das heißt, wir haben Netzwerkabeln neu gepatcht
Videokonferenzanlage installiert
Und auch Druck umgezogen
Das war eine tolle Erfahrung
Drucker umziehen, beste
Ich finde es hartnäckige Probleme gibt, die von mir gelöst werden können
Dass die Kollegen dann wieder fröhlich weiterarbeiten können
In Wirklichkeit ist es so
Helpdesk ist es nicht so
Dass die Kollegen dann fröhlich weiterarbeiten
Die gehen ja permanent auf den Sack
Und tun so, als wärst du dran schuld
Ich hab mich schon immer für Computer interessiert
Ganz früher mit Spielen
Der Rechner ist aber auch Hardcore Oldschool
Von wann ist denn das?
Ach, das Video ist von 2015
Ok, jetzt ergibt das Ganze
Auch ein bisschen mehr Sinn
Weil das ist Hardcore Oldschool
Parallelport
Was ist denn das? VGA?
VGA, DVI, vielleicht ist das schon HDMI
PS2 Ports
VGA, was ist das für ein Rechner?
Selbst für 2015 ist das
Antik
Ganz früher mit Spielen
Später dann mit Webentwicklung
Und jetzt bin ich echt glücklich, dass ich das hier
In meinem Beruf ausüben kann
Ich finde es ist ein gutes Arbeitsklima
Weil man mit guten Kollegen zusammenarbeitet
Und wenn irgendwelche Fragen oder Probleme sind
Immer auf die zugehen kann
Wir sind hier in der IT für alle Standorte weltweit zuständig
Die müssen natürlich auch regelmäßig besucht werden
Sei es Barcelona, Manchester
Oder Shenyang
Das ist cool für Leute, die das gerne machen
Ich mache das nicht gerne
Ich gehe gerne morgens auf die Arbeit
Verdiene mein Geld und gehe heim
Und mache dann was ich will
Und das kann ich nicht machen, wenn ich irgendwo anders bin
Bin mal gespannt, wo ich hinkommen werde
Aber das ist Geschmackste
Es gibt Leute, die machen das gerne
Nach meiner Ausbildung möchte ich hier weiterarbeiten
Und mich auch fachlich durch verschiedene Zertifikate und Schulungen weiterentwickeln
Mein Ziel ist es hier die Ausbildung erfolgreich abzuschließen
In der Abteilung weiterzuarbeiten
Und in der Zukunft natürlich auch noch nicht
Mit diversen IT Zertifikaten weiterzubilden
Warum wollen die alle Zertifikate haben?
Zertifikate
Das einzige wofür du Zertifikate brauchst
Ist weil irgendwelche
Stonksleute der Meinung sind
Zertifikate sagen was aus
Sonst ist das Zertifikat für ein Arsch
Nicht der Inhalt den man lernt
Um Zertifikate zu machen
Die sind nicht für ein Arsch
Das sind für ein Arsch
Irgendwie, ich muss mir den Typ angucken
Der seinen Rechner einbaut
Ich mag so Handwerks-Skills-Videos
Irgendwie
Und oftmals fällt mir dabei
Sachen ein, die ich selber bauen könnte
Wenn man einen Job bekommen will
Zählen nur Zertifikate
Sagt der Eisenhauer
Wie sieht das aus?
Gerade im IT Bereich
Du hast bestimmt noch ein paar Unternehmen
Die da richtig krass drauf gucken
Mich würde es wundern, wenn du nur mit Zertifikaten Jobs kriegst
Und außerdem gibt es Zertifikate gratis vor Let's Encrypt
So sieht es aus
Es schadet sicherlich nichts wenn man irgendein Zertifikat hat
Die Musik dabei
Was da am Ende rauskommt
Da können wir wissen, es ist ein eingebauter PC mit Wasserkühlung
Spoiler
Oh, oh
Und die teuren RGB-Lüfter
Monka RGB
Wie viele Lüfter baut der denn da ein
Das Ding kann ja abheben
Das ist ja eine halbe Turbine
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass die teurer als von Corsair sind
Die Corsair RGB-Lüfter sind schon unnützteuer
Hat noch Tour-RGB-Lüfter
Der FPS Boost ist nicht zu unterscheiden
Ich glaube, der ist nicht zu unterscheiden
Ja, richtig, korrekt
Der Chat kennt sich aus
Oh, sogar mit Logo
Das ist die Wasserkühlung
Oder, Chat?
Ich vermute, das ist die Wärmetauscher von der Wasserkühlung
Oder irgendwie sowas
Ja, da kommt danach
Das kommt auf die Lüfter drauf
Das ist der Wärmetauscher
Was ein Tryhard
Ich gucke sowas echt gern
Wo Leute so gewisse Fingerfertigkeit haben
Und sowas zusammenbauen
Und oftmals hat man da gute Ideen, was man selbst bauen könnte
Also, ich kriege sowas hier nicht gebacken
Da habe ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht die Geduld für
Aber manche Sachen sieht man, denkt sich
Oh, das ist nicht schlecht
Das könnte man auch bei was Eigenem gebrauchen
Oh, ein Lüfter, der sich dreht
Poggers
Jetzt erstmal
Windows Installation anschmeißen danach
Äh
SATA Kabel? Nee
Eigentlich ist da Power Knopf
und Front USB
Lüfter hat
echt viele drinnen
Das ist der Power Button gewesen
Erstmal einen 1000 Watt Netzteil rein
Weil es geht, YOLO
Okay, das wird irgendein Ryzen System
Rützen
Was ist es denn für ein Rützen?
Habt ihr es gesehen? 3900 X
Kann das sein?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Habt ihr es erkannt?
X, auf jeden Fall ein X hinten
Aber der Rest ist verdeckt
3700 X, okay
Der Witz ist ja nicht in die Beschreibung
Gucken wir das trotzdem raus
Ich hab nie gedacht
Ich hab mir damals genau den gleichen RAM gekauft
Auch diese G-Skill RGB Dinger
Und ich hab damals nicht für möglich gehalten
Dass die mal so populär werden
Weil es ist im Prinzip einfach nur über
Extrem überteuerte, sinnlose RGB RAM
Und mittlerweile
Egal wo ich gucke, PC Build
Jeder nimmt diese komische G-Skill
R&RGB RAMs
Und ich frag mich warum
Das frag ich mich bei mir auch
Warum ich die genommen hab
Weil es total sinnlos
FPS Boost
Stimmt hab ich ganz vergessen
Choice of Champions
Gibt es eigentlich was neues zum Dr. Disrespect-Bun?
Oh, der Lüfter ist nicht advanced genug
Da muss jetzt ein extra RGB Lüfter rein
Eigentlich für die Wasserkühlung wahrscheinlich
Also mich hätte es jetzt nicht gewundert
Wenn er den Lüfter ausgetauscht hätte
Zu einem RGB Lüfter
Eisenhower, das ist das
Confirmed
Und für die Jawohl
So, erstmal Grafikkarte ausbauen
Und Wasserkühlung-Stells drauf machen
Das ist eine Vermutung von dir
Ich hab auch viele Vermutungen
Meine Vermutung ist auch Plattformwechsel
Oh, siehste
Schon hat er mich auf eine Idee gebracht
Ich wollte mir schon die ganze Zeit
Mal ein Skalpell bestellen
Für Pakete
Für Tüten aufmachen
Für irgendwelche Sachen abschneiden
Chirurg-FPS am Start
Nicht AliExpress
Weil das echt praktisch ist
Genau für so Sachen
Wenn du mal irgendwas abschneiden musst
Wenn du gerade irgendwelche Elektronik-Sachen basteln
So ein Skalpell ist teilweise echt praktisch
Und zum Unboxen
Bringt
Teinsa fragt
Bringt ne NVMe mit Heatsink eigentlich was
Sehe das mega oft in Build
Ja und Nee
Also ja, insofern
Die Dinger werden tatsächlich sau heiß
Nee, in Form von
Wenn du ein bisschen Luftfluss im Gehäuse hast
Und da jetzt keine Benchmarks einen ganzen Tag
drauf machst
Dann brauchst du es wahrscheinlich nicht
Aber es schadet auf jeden Fall nichts
Jetzt kommt
Die Wasserkühlung
Was macht der denn jetzt
Ah, die Rückseite
Für den Wasserkühler
Das sieht so ordentlich aus auch
Mega ordentlich
Alter, guckt euch das mal an
Der hat sogar so Abstandshalter dran
Das sieht extrem ordentlich aus
Das wird bei mir im Leben nicht so gut aussehen
Oh jetzt Big Brain Aufbau
Jetzt kommt die Wasserkühlung
Anschlüsse für die Wasserkühlung
Ja, das vorher zu planen
Ist wirklich nicht ohne
Heißkleber
Oder? Nee
Nee, Moment, was
Ah, das ist das
Dass die Schläuche elastisch werden
Boah ey
Ich würde Zustände kriegen dabei
Weil ich
Ich bleib bei sowas immer schnell ungeduldig
Und wenn dann was kaputt geht
Rage ich rum und schmeiß manchmal die Sachen runter
Weil es mich so aufregt
Weil ich verkackt hab
Gestern beim Zusammenspiel
Ich hab mir gesagt
Gestern beim
Zusammenlöten von
Den kleinen Kontakten an diesem China stick
Hab ich euch ja das Bild gezeigt
Da hätte ich auch was runter geschmissen
Weil ich zweimal wieder abgelötet hab
Ausversehen das Teil nebendran
Hier das da, das meine ich
Für die die es gestern nicht gesehen haben
In welche Anlagenform investierst
Du eigentlich
Bin nicht so big
im stonks game
ja vm
komm starten
remind me later
hier guckt mal die
post image
kann das sein dass ich das gestern hier so geauft hatte
ahja hier genau
da habe ich echt anfälle gekriegt
diese sachen dran zu löten hier
moment
das ist nämlich wirklich klein
ähm
weil ihr seht ja das hier sind smd komponenten
und die sind schon eklig klein
und da muss ich halt normale normale kabels dran löten und
da habe ich
ne und ich habe es ja so gemacht ich habe eins oben gelötet eins unten gelötet
eins oben gelötet eins unten gelötet oder
umgedreht
also sprich eins oben dran dann eins unten dran
dass sie sich nicht in die quere gekommen sind
und trotzdem hatte ich das problem
dass wenn ich
das da fest gelötet haben das da abgegangen ist teilweise und sowas
richtig eklig richtig eklig
aber es hat funktioniert hat alles funktioniert
wir haben sie dann geflasht bekommen
ja
aber die musik
ähm warum ist das
da innen drin so
bildschick
habe
style g
was ist denn style g
oder einfach nur style
ich dachte style g ist vielleicht das womit man das färbt
leuchtet besser
ah ja gut wenn es beleuchten willst das kann natürlich sein ja
es sieht ziemlich gut aus
exzellent
ach es wird auch noch ein tisch eingebaut jetzt wird es aber richtig advanced hier
der kann das bild weiterverwenden
ich meine da hat es ja so gebaut dass da normales atx mainboard reinbaut das ist
sogar ab upgradable
nachdem er es wieder aus dem tisch ausgebaut hat
das ist richtig gut
ja
ich meine cool sieht es aus
stimmt staubfilter unbedingt staubfilter braucher
staubfilter muss sein
das sieht sehr entzündlich aus nur was soll denn da brennen also wenn jetzt
nicht gerade das netzteil abfackelt und anfängt zu brennen brennt das auch nicht
lohnt sich eigentlich dieses ganze asus rock zeug
ne nicht wirklich
also mich wird es irritieren
also wenn ich hier spielen würde da hätte ich permanent im augenwinkel
hätte ich die rgb beleuchtung
ich würde es wahrscheinlich zudecken
der tisch sieht unbequem aus
es sieht cool aus aber ich glaube das wäre kein setup wo ich täglich dran
spielen möchte oder streamen möchte oder programmieren möchte oder was auch
immer
der tisch ist ein bisschen unspektakulär
ich mag unspektakuläre tische und stühle
halt welche die gut sind
die sehen meistens unspektakulär aus ja
deswegen habe ich auch kein gaming tisch und kein gaming stuhl
sondern einfach
in richtig guten tisch und in richtig guten stuhl
die sind zwar null gaming
aber sind besser als gaming stühle und gaming tische und was sie nicht alles
gibt
das sind 3800 x war es
also wer ist mir nicht toll es gibt gaming desk
da habe ich mal eine anfragung bekommen ob ich nicht
werbung für einen
gaming desk machen möchte
das war aber nicht der glaube ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher
wir haben uns ja mal zusammen angeguckt damals
und ich hab den zurückgeschrieben was denn ihren gaming desk auszeichnet
gegenüber normalen anderen tischen und da habe ich nie wieder antwort bekommen
welchen stuhl hast du ich habe einen
ist auf 24
den da
beste stuhl den es gibt
gehen wir weg mit herrmann miller oder sonst irgendwelchen dingern
das ist der beste stuhl den es gibt
change my mind
der kein besseren stuhl
kannst alles verstellen sowohl höhe als auch hier neben also wenn man
besonders pepe fett ist
da kann man auch hier neben das auseinander machen da passen
ist zugelassen bis also ist standardlich bis 250 kilo
bis 250 kilo
und das also das reicht also auch für massiv kokona
kopflehnen gibt es in zwei varianten es gibt die die habe ich
und es gibt die die haben wir auf der arbeit
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen dass ich
die kopflehne die ich hier gar nicht so gut finde deswegen habe ich noch ein
zusätzliches kissen drüber
und damit ist das gut also ich habe hier noch so ein kissen drüber
optimal
ist finde ich den besten stuhl es gibt investition
dann nicht fürs leben aber für längere zeit
würdest du den nein
kusswort würde ich nicht
ganz in die ganzen gaming stühle das sagt einfach
und wenn ihr wirklich was günstiges haben wollte holt euch mein wegen ikea
markus oder sowas
diesen ganzen dx racer gaming share crap ist einfach nur müll
ein schnapper
der stuhl kostet wenn du vom hersteller ohne irgendwas bestellt glaube ich
1200 euro aber das macht ja keiner
muss irgendwo gucken dass du ihn günstig kriegst also ich denke mal man hat die
chancen den schon für 7 800 euro zu kriegen
das ist dann auch ok 1300 euro ist ein bisschen viel
gaming share mit lgb ich finde es komplett
ich hatte ja selbst mal ein dx racer
da ist anstelle ist an der stelle gehofft durchgebrochen
ähm
wo den stuhl eigentlich nicht durchbrechen sollte
nämlich unten
da sind ja die rechte
die rechte arme auflage ist aus dem tür aus dem aus dem stuhl rahmen
rausgebrochen beim dx racer den ich hatte
und es war auch ein dx racer der ist
zu also der ist gemacht gewesen für den gewicht deutlich über mir
ähm
auch diese ledergeschichte finde ich das ist dieses fake leder von den gaming
shares finde ich auch extrem
äh unangenehm auf dauer
ansonsten muss man einfach mal ausprobieren aber jeder mister 24 ist
wirklich
der beste stuhl den ich den auf dem ich je gesessen habe
es ist umsonst so dass ich mir den stuhl gekauft habe für über 1000 euro
äh
das hätte ich sonst nie gemacht hätte ich nicht für für
klonswert gehalten
welchen stuhl hast du den hier den den hier
mit dieser mit dieser ich habe ihn in schwarz-grau
sieht man das hier nicht richtig
teils schwarz teils grau
mit stoff
es sieht ungefähr genauso aus nur dass es nur dass es grau ist das polster und
die rückenlehne
ähm und man darf sich vom preis nicht so sehr abschrecken lassen
weil man muss gucken dass man ihn
man muss gucken dass es einen shop gibt der gerade irgendwie sagt ok wir haben
noch fünf stück zu viel mit grauen muster und dann kauft man sich das also
nicht für 1200
also für wenn man wenn man ihn irgendwie für 8 900 kriegt oder so dann ist ok
aber dafür würde ich ihn auch nicht kaufen und dafür ist recht nicht
von steuern abgesetzt habe ich ihn
allerdings kriegt man dafür halt auch ersatzteile was sehr praktisch ist
und letztendlich überlegt euch mal es ist eine investition
ähnlich zu einem ordentlichen headset
oder zu sagen wir so zur ordentlichen küche oder was auch immer
ähm das sind sachen die habt ihr ja nicht nur zwei drei jahre
wie vielleicht ich weiß der krieger hat den auch ja wir haben den
unabhängig voneinander gekauft wusste bis bis
vor nicht ganz so langer zeit gar nicht dass der den hat
ähm
solche sachen
das ist ja eine investition für 2
nicht für 23 jahre sondern
die könnt ihr ohne probleme zehn jahre mindestens verwenden den stuhl
mindestens die könnte 20 jahre verwenden den stuhl den ich hier habe
den habe ich mir glaub gekauft irgendwie 2000 ich weiß nicht mehr 2014 oder so
der ist sechs jahre alt du siehst dem nichts an der ist wie neu
und kopfhörer ist auch so ein ding wenn man sich irgendwann mal einen ordentlichen kopfhörer
gekauft hat
den kann man auch lange verwenden oder man macht so bescheuert wie ich
und kauft sich drei stück hängt oder auf fünf stück mittlerweile hängt die
sich an die wand und verwendet außerdem
ein kein
welche kopfhörer also aktuell habe ich gerade ein headset auf
ist das bayer dynamics mx 300
das ist quasi den dt 770 mit mit mikrofon
ansonsten habe ich noch was habe ich da hinten alles hängen akg 701
nenn
und
noch den noch den bayer dynamics dt
top 990 ist das das ist der der offen ist
dann ein audio techniker
t-bar fragt mich nicht so und so ein ding was angeblich besonders bequem auf dem
kopf ist
und eigentlich habe ich nur mal mit 300 auf unsinnig viele kopfhörer gekauft aber
immer nur mx 300 auf
wie findest du akg im vergleich zu bayer also der
klang vom akg 701 ist deutlich neutraler als vom mx 300
ähm also
mit der dt 770 beziehungsweise halt das mx 300 ist halt eher so eine
badewanne vom sound her
der
das das das ding von akg ist viel neutraler
allerdings habe ich noch die alte version
die diese hubbel hier hatte und das das tut mir auf den kopf weh
die neue version haben keine hubbel mehr
die hubbel tun mir auf den kopf weh
so es gibt jede menge gute kopfhörer aber wusste was darum geht ist
ähm benutzt du auch das mikrofon vom mx 300 ja
ist angenehmer als irgendwie ein standmikrofon
aber das ist ein relativ gutes
mikro im vergleich zu den anderen headset mikros natürlich kein vergleich zu einem
richtig ordentlichen mikro aber
ähm zu den anderen headsets mikros ist das ist das ziemlich gut
ähm
und
man kauft die sicher auch nicht
alle zwei monate neu oder alle zwei jahre neu
das mx 300 habe ich gekauft vor acht jahren oder so und ist immer noch top
das einzige was man wechseln kann ist das polster
ich habe auch einen
ec rbs ich habe auch noch einen quiet comfort 35
noise cancelling
ähm
für für unterwegs per bluetooth
allerdings ist der sound
nicht so schön wie beispielsweise mit einem mit hier mit dem akg oder
ich finde ihn auch nicht so schön wie ft wie von hier dem mf von dem dt 770
das ist halt durch das ganze noise cancelling und dass es halt ziemlich auf
die ohren gedrückt ist dann
wirkt irgendwie ein bisschen
gestaucht alles
aber dafür ist es in der bahn super man hört drum herum keine schreienden kinder
oder sonstige sachen
dafür ist er da
ok was passiert wenn eine atom bombe deine stadt trifft das gucken wir uns
jetzt noch an
also ich behaupte mal wir sind alle alle one hit
explosionen feuerbälle schockwellen strahlung
das ist wie in videos mit atomwaffen rumzuspielen macht deshalb großen spaß
das mag uns unsere zerstörungen ich mag den sprecher von den videos da spricht
er auch die englischen videos oder spricht er auch die englischen
ich glaube da spricht er auch die englischen videos
mir kommt er in dem übelst ne
der sprecher kommt übelst bekannt vor
sind die industrial revolution ne humans have released tatsächlich das sind andere
der hört sich aber sehr ähnlich an
south america and oceania together only contributed eight percent
aber der hört sich wirklich ähnlich an von von der stimmlage her und wie er
spricht
zu vor Augen führen
die echten Auswirkungen einer Atomexplosion zeigt es aber nicht
wir sprechen ja nicht von rumalbern mit TNT oder der Helligkeit einer
Explosion
bei atomwaffen geht es um dein Leben
angeregt von der rotkreuz und der rothalbmond
organisator mein leben bin ich ja froh dass so mein leben geht dann ist
wenigstens
das von anderen er ist aber hauptsache es geht um eins
haben wir deshalb nachgeforscht was wirklich passieren würde wenn heute eine
atomwaffe in einer großstadt detonierte
kein atomkrieg nur eine einzige explosion
wir beginnen mitten im zentrum einer großstadt
die menschen sind auf dem weg zur arbeit lernen für prüfungen und gehen
ihrem täglichen leben nach
genau hier und jetzt detoniert
die zeit steht still
die erste phase der explosion geschieht in weniger als einer sekunde
in einem millisekunde erscheint ein plasma ball heißer als die sonne
er wird zu einem feuerball von mehr als zwei kilometern durchmesser
innerhalb dieser kugel ist alles einfach weg
die wasser das in die bratpfanne topft
ein zwischen
dann nichts
die meisten geborenen also wenn ich die auswahl hätte
finde ich das gar nicht so schlecht weil man möglichst nah dran ist
weil davon kriegst du nichts mit
du bist du bist einfach du bist einfach weg
du bist du bist einfach nicht mehr da
aus bäume statuen und menschen
in luft aufgelöst
für einen kurzen moment durchdringt ein gleißender licht blitz die stadt
solltest du zufällig gerade in die richtung der explosion blicken
erblendest du für mehrere stunden
die hitze die von diesem blitz ausgeht
erzeugt einen wärmeimpuls von unermesslicher energie
er ist so heiß
dass er in einem umkreis von bis zu dreizehn kilometern und die
detonation alles ansteckt
auf einem gebiet von 500 quadratkilometern verbrennt also alles
was brennt monachs plastikholz textilien haut und da bist du in reichweite dieses
werden wir also dass deswegen deswegen ich will lieber direkt dort stehen wo
die bombe einschlägt da bin ich wenigstens direkt weg
das ist mir lieber als verbrennen
in einem moment vielleicht gerade zur arbeit
und im nächsten in flammen auf
jetzt beginnt die zweite phase
sie dauert nur wenige sekunden
die meisten menschen merken erst jetzt dass etwas nicht stimmt
für hunderttausende ist es aber bereits zu spät
dem blitz folgt eine drucke
durch die hitze und strahlung des feuerballs entsteht eine blase
die von sehr heißer stark komprimierte luft umgeben ist
sie dehnt sich explosionsartig aus mit überschallgeschwindigkeit
dabei entstehen stürme die stärker sind als hurricanes oder tornadoes
unsere infrastruktur ist dieser wucht nicht gewachsen
einen kilometer rund um den feuerball werden die meisten großen gebäude einfach
zermahlen
nur stahlbeton
kann dem druck teilweise standhalten
in den parks in denen eben noch rentner enten fütterten knicken die bereits
verkohlten blimmenden bäume um wie zahnstocher
endlich weg mit dem entener
pustet es dich weg wie ein staubkorn in einem tornado
nach außen wird die druckwelle schwächer
aber trotzdem stürzen in einem umkreis von 175 quadratkilometern
die gebäude ein wie kartenhäuser
zehntausende von menschen
denen keine zeit zum reagieren blieb
werden unter ihnen begraben
tankstellen fliegen in die luft
feuer breiten sich in den trümmern aus
in den nächsten minuten steigt ein kilometerhoher atompilz auf
er besteht aus den überresten des feuerballs staub und asche
und wirft einen dunklen schatten
deswegen home office dann ist man einfach nicht da
die aufsteigende wolke sorgt frische luft an
dieser sturm zerstört noch mehr gebäude
und bringt haufe es rettet leben wie ihr seht ja
was als nächstes passiert hängt von der stadt ab
gibt es genug brennstoff entsteht ein feuersturm der alles verbrennt
die trümmer alle die darin eingeschlossen sind
und die flüchtenden menschen
in bis zu 21 kilometer entfernung
stürzen menschen wie du und ich ans fenster um die pilzwolke zu knipsen
ihnen ist nicht bewusst dass die stoßwelle auf sie zu rast
und das fenster gleich in einen sturm von scharfen scherben verwandeln wird
jetzt beginnt die dritte phase
sie dauert die nächsten stunden und tage
wir sind es gewohnt dass hilfe kommt egal wie schlimm das unglück ist
aber jetzt nicht
eine atom explosion ist ungefähr so als würden alle naturkatastrophen auf
einmal passieren
hunderttausende oder sogar millionen menschen sind schwer verletzt
fleischwunden knochenbrüche schwere verbrennungen
in den nächsten minuten und stunden sterben tausende an diesen
verletzungen
unzählige menschen sind in den eingestürzten gebäuden eingeschlossen
wie bei einem erdbeben
vom blitz geblendet
oder taub von der drohquelle
monke es
trümmer und schutt versperren die straßen
alle sind verängstigt und verwirrt
keiner weiß was eigentlich passiert ist
sehr wahrscheinlich wurden auch die krankenhäuser dem erdboden gleich
gemacht
und die meisten mediziner sind tot oder verletzt
wie alle anderen auch
manche hatten glück
und befanden sich gerade in der u-bahn oder an einer stelle wo sie wieder
verletzt noch verbrannt wurden
aber auch sie sind dem schrecken noch nicht entkommen
je nach art der bombe dem ort der detonation und im wetter setzt jetzt ein
schrecklicher schwarzer regen
dadurch senkt sich radioaktive asche über die stadt
die alles und alle bedeckt
jetzt setzt der unsichtbare türkische stille schrecken der verstrahlung ein
mit jedem atemzug gelangt gift in die lungen der überlebenden diejenigen die
die höchste strahlendosis abbekommen haben sterben
in den nächsten tagen
es wird keine hilfe kommen
stundenlang nicht vielleicht auch tagelang
bricht die infrastruktur zusammen
funktioniert die zivilisation nicht mehr
blockierte straßen verdrehte gleise fluchtwege von trümmern versperrt kein
wasser kein strom kann kommunikation
keine supermärkte wo man sich mit vorräten eindecken könnte
hilfe aus benachbarten städten kann kaum ins katastrophengebiet gelangen
und selbst wenn macht die radioaktive kontamination es riskant sich zu nähern
nach einem atomangriff bist du auf dich allein gestellt
nach und nach erscheinen die menschen aus den trümmern zu fuß verstrahlt
mit dem wenigen besitz auf dem rücken den sie noch haben
langsam verletzt
genau wir würden erst mal klopapier einkaufen geht
sie alle brauchen so schnell wie möglich etwas zu essen wasser
und medizinische versorgung
und der schrecken eines atomangriffs endet nicht wenn das feuer ausgebrannt
der rauch verflogen ist
die benachbarten krankenhäuser sind nicht für eine katastrophe dieser
größenordnung ausgerüstet
sie sind überfordert von den zehn oder hunderttausenden von schwerverletzten
in den nächsten wochen monaten und jahren werden viele der überlebenden
krebs erkrankungen wie leukämie bekommen
unseren regierungen ist es lieber wenn wir über all das nicht zu viel
nachdenken denn sie wissen dass es auf eine atomexplosion gar keine
ernstzunehmende humanitäre reaktion geben kann
wir können den opfern eines atomangriffs nicht wirklich helfen
das hier ist wie ein hurricane flächenbrand erdbeben und atomunfall
gleichzeitig aber noch schlimmer
kein land der welt kann damit umgehen
in den letzten jahren hat sich die weltpolitik verändert
weltmächte drohen sich wieder stellezbomber
viele experten sind der meinung dass die gefahr für einen atomangriff heute so
hoch ist wie seit jahrzehnten nicht mehr
regierungen erzählen ihren bürgern dass wir atomwaffen brauchen
aber die anderen sie nicht haben dürfen
dass wir für unsere eigene sicherheit anderen mit massenvernichtung drohen
müssen
aber fühlst du dich dadurch wirklich sicher es reichen ein paar wenige größen
wahnsinnige oder abtrünnige machthaber ein kleiner fehlt oder ein bloßes
missverständnis um eine katastrophe unvorstellbaren ausmaßes auszulösen
in einem video dinge in die luft zu jagen mag spaß machen
in echt ganz und gar nicht
aber es gibt eine lösung
alle atomwaffen zu zerstören und zu schwören nie wieder welche zu bauen
er das mit der unterstützung von hunderten zivile organisationen
das ist eine gute idee da müssen alle mitmachen
allen rotkreuz und ruht halbmond organisation
haben 2017 fast zwei drittel aller länder der welt zugestimmt
atomwaffen abzuschaffen und zu verbieten
es geht nicht darum wer die waffen hat und wer nicht
die waffen selbst sind das problem
sie sind höchst unmoralisch
und eine existenzielle gefahr für uns alle
egal aus welchem land du kommst
wurde dich politisch einordnest
wir müssen fordern dass atomwaffen für immer verschwinden
wenn wir keinen druck machen wird das so lange du auch du so lange es hat nicht
alle machen sagen dann wieder
von der anderen seiten welche auch halb auch irgendwo zurecht so nach dem motto
ähm ja wenn die welche haben dann brauchen wir ja auch welche dass wir
was haben
ne als antwort und dass wir dann auch den drohen können wenn die uns drohen
und so
dieses drucks werden
informiere dich schließe dich einer organisation gegen atomwaffen an
und wähle politiker die sich für das thema stark machen
exzellent
jetzt wissen wir bescheid also
sollte demnächst in frankfurt atombombe explodieren wissen
wissen wir dass wir nichts dagegen machen können und äh
den löffel abgeben
wo wir grad dabei sind wir können uns auch nach mp3 moab angucken
das war gerade mal gut ist keine atombombe
ähm
das stimmt medics aber es funktioniert zurzeit ganz gut
frag mich was es wäre wenn das wenn
wenn man das nicht machen könnte
da ist die moab
nuke video
hallo musik
wie findest du das nordkorea linux redstar os das gibt es doch schon gar
nicht mehr
das war vor ein paar jahren mal angesagt das haben die wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mehr
wie viel bauten wir davon noch
das antitelefon
wolvo bliesbrenn
schau mal das simplissimus video an welches
simplissimus zum
wie drei deutsche im darknet reich wurden auch nie
da habe ich jetzt kein bock drauf
bratwurst
wie ist nix interessantes mehr dabei gerade
steek japan
schweizer rösti selber machen
ich habe hunger
fährt mir gerade so ein
irgendwie nix spannendes mehr dabei gerade
mal bettel für sich so ist es
also was ich mir wünsche bettel für sechs ist
dass sie einfach mal wieder den game machen was ich gerne spiele
ich will ich wünsche mir gar nichts spezielles
ich will einfach wieder den game
was ich so anfühlt als stirbt nicht morgen
ist es interessant zu spielen als gibt es genug aspekte dass man das auch eine
weile spielen kann
und als hat man einfach bock sich einzuloggen und zu spielen
ich habe ich habe wirklich gar keine großartige wünschung ist ich will
einfach im game mit dem bettel viel spieler
wo man bock hat sich einzuloggen zu spielen was nicht abfragt
guckst du beauty and the north
das ist klick nach in der bescheuerten rtl sendung
feig zahnbürsten für 99 euro brief vom anwalt
es gibt nichts gibt nichts gescheites was man sich angucken kann gerade
cookie
clicker explain was muss du denn an cookie clicker explain
klicks drauf
ok ja wenn ihr das gucken wollt
ok
hausaufgaben
die drei deutsche im dark natural reich wurden
sollten alle menschen veganer wenn auch das triggert bestimmt hat irgendwelche
das video ist nicht so
ja was denn jetzt der chat hat mir jetzt erst
er sagt ich soll mir das unbedingt angucken wäre super interessant jetzt
kommt der nächste sagt das video wäre nicht so gut
jetzt zu spät
die dunkle seite des
oh nee wenn das wenn ich mir das intro schon anhöre das dark net ist die dunkle
seite des internets nutzer sind anonym server versteckt der hört sich übelst
an wie willi peter kaster typ
darknet gibt es plattformen ganz ähnlich zu ebay oder amazon allerdings
kauft man auf solchen seiten nicht nur gebrauchte langhandeln oder ein buch
von karsten maschmeyer sondern drogen gestohlene kreditkarten manchmal auch
waffen oder sogar ganze identitäten
heute geht es nein wir haben vorhin gelernt dass man dort auch lebern und
herzen kaufen kann das ist ja viel interessanter um die geschichte des
zweitgrößten dieser darknet märkte überhaupt was sie kreut
ach nee
ne warte mal ne warte mal was war was war sie kreut noch mal
was sie kreut nicht auch so was
einem drogentoten in florida über mef dealer in kalifornien zu einem
community manager in sao paulo
sie erzählt von einer gigantischen falle und einem bunker in traben
an der mosel sie erzählt auch in deutschland größten scams der
geschichte des dar
also ich weiß dass er damit nicht
meint
das meint er damit nicht aber aber da bei bitcoins und scam ist das das erste
was mir einfällt
von millionensummen in bitcoin hunderttausenden euro bargeld und einem
weißen mercedes amg gts
letztendlich erzählt sich von drei jungen warum fahren eigentlich die
möchte gern kriminellen gangster
immer die gleichen autos
den administratoren
dies ist die geschichte wie sie zu fall gebracht
der wall street market war riesig und professionell aufgestellt auf der
website gab es circa 63.000 verkaufsangebote von rund viereinhalb
tausend händlern dazu kamen über eine millionen kunden konnten
es gab bewertungssysteme für händler ein eigenes forum und einen subreddit im
normalen internet man konnte mit bitcoin und monero bezahlen die
kryptowährungen gewährleistet monero jetzt weiß ich auch warum christiano
ronaldo
auf seiner webseite monero gemeint hat
der wollte sich sicherlich was im bar im im dark web kaufen
alle parteien wäre jetzt ergibt alles sind anonymen blieben
die betreiber waren mutmaßlich drei deutsche koda 420 ein damals 22
der nabe das ist ja der beste nabe überhaupt
koda 420 das ist ja der meme nabe schlechtern
aus kleve der damals 29 jährige dauer und der damals 31 jährige kronos sie
bekamen circa zwei bis sechs prozenten provisionen für jede transaktion auf
der plattform im zentrum der wachsenden forren war kronos nicht den wo sie
durchs fenster des notebook geklaut haben oder war das wieder was ganz was
anderes community manager medellin er hat für die drei betreiber sowohl den
subreddit als auch das eigene forum der plattform moderiert dafür bekam er
1200 dollar pro monat zwei der größten händler auf der plattform waren zum
beispiel lady skywalker und platinum 45 beide hatten ihren sitz in
kalifornien und haben diverse harte drogen verkauft
ein weiterer us-händler war u4 a an seinen drogen ist 2017 ein mann in
florida gestorben international gab es großes interesse all diese menschen
festzunehmen sie wurden jahrelang verfolgt vom fbi was
bekommen die mots hier cute chat anerkennung europol dem bka und der
niederländischen polizei ok so viel zu den akteuren aber darknet was bedeutet
das eigentlich websites die man nicht über einen normalen browser erreichen
kann nennt man hidden services diese sind in der regeln das ist quasi das
black life matters internet sogenannte torrnetzwerk abrufbar hier verbindet man
sich über einen besonderen browser mit zufälligen servern innerhalb eines
netzwerks keine der einzelnen stationen kennt die gesamte route so bleiben der
nutzer und sein standort verschleiert auch wenn man zum beispiel einfach google
auf ruft nur den standort vom jeweiligen ausgang richtig ein hidden service
befindet sich mitten innerhalb dieses geschlossenen netzwerkes und bleibt so
versteckt die behörden stehen jetzt vor der aufgabe dieses das muss ich mal
unser unser spezialer zubi nehmen wir hatten der kam auch eines tages an und
hat ganz stolz erzählt er verwendet jetzt für alles torr
ich versuch zu erklären dass ich da ich bin ich so ganz sicher bin ob das so eine
tolle idee ist sein normales zeugs auch über torr zu machen weil gerade diese
exit node geschichten wenn man sich mal so anguckt wer unter anderem exit nodes
betreibt ich weiß man kann das auswählen du kannst davon ausgehen dass dort ein
traffic auf jeden fall mitgelesen wird zu finden wie die aufgabe so einen
hidden service zu finden ist natürlich am anfang relativ kompliziert es gibt
zunächst mal theoretisch über vier milliarden ip adressen zur auswahl aber
nur wenige davon nutzen tatsächlich auch torr das ist linus neumann hacker
netzaktivist und sprecher des chaos computer clubs das torrnetzwerk ist also
nicht wirklich riesig nehmen wir an man kontrolliert viele der server des
netzwerks überall auf der welt jetzt könnte man wahlweise die eigenen server
drosseln während man den wall street market anfragt dann kann man vielleicht
irgendwann sehen welche drosselungen in welcher region der welt die antworten
des wall street market servers verlangsamt dann weiß man plötzlich ok
der server ist wahrscheinlich in europa dann testet man weiter
dieses land wahrscheinlich und dann gibt es natürlich noch excellent beginn an
relativ einfache hypothesen wo sich solche server befinden
das stimmt das stimmt das darf man nicht vergessen egal was er was was er sagt
aber es gibt ja auch nicht so unendlich viele länder wo sowas gerne gehostet
wird auch nicht unendlich viele provider die die sowas hausten also jedem host
da auf diesem planeten ohne probleme so ein server unterbringen kann
das hat vermutlich so wie beschrieben einen server des wall street markets in
den niederlanden identifiziert das bka hat parallel außerdem weitere server in
deutschland gefunden
traben trabach ein städtchen mit rund 6000 einwohnern bekannt für wein und
mosel romantik hier standen jahrelang server auf den illegale seiten
gespeichert waren auch online marktplätze auf den drogen gehandelt
wurde der hauptverdächtige kaufte den bunker 2013 von der bundeswehr auch die
verbreitung den bunker den bunker ich brauche ich will auch ich will auch
mein eigener bunker
ein bunker ist doch top so wie kim dot com der hat auch seinen eigenen bunker
gehabt
da machst du dann dein ein machen wir einen weinkeller machen wir dann in
bunker wörtlich ein bunker voller server bei traben trabach an der mosel
viele dieser server wurden für hidden services genutzt die betreiber wurden
mittlerweile angeklagt lange vor ihrer verhaftung hatten sie schon einmal
besuch von der polizei die ermittler fanden einige server des wall street
markt stimmt der bunker ist jetzt frei richtig und ich glaube wenn man dort
einen weinkeller rein machen will sind ja auch eher damit einverstanden wie man
wieder ein rechenzentrum rein machen will da konnten die behörden den
datenverkehr zum server hin und zurück beobachten
jetzt waren sie den betreibern ganz dicht auf den fersen
ende märz 2019 machte der damals größte darknet markt die schotten dicht in der
folge boomte das geschäft auf dem wall street market
es gab zahlreiche neue händler und kunden die admins nutzten die gelegenheit
vielleicht hatten sie auch einfach angst jedenfalls haben sie im april 2019
mutmaßlich einen exit scam durchgezogen darknet merkte lagern das geld aus
transaktionen zwischen kunden und händlern zeitweise zwischen um scams
vorzubeugen nun wenn die eigene seite groß genug ist liegt in diesem
zwischenlager zeitweise richtig richtig viel geld wenn die betreiber sich also
entscheiden dieses geld einfach zu behalten und damit abzuhauen ist das
ein exit scam genau das haben die drei admins mutmaßlich getan und so
höchstwahrscheinlich mindestens zehn millionen euro ordentlich von ihren
kunden und händlern gestohlen aber das geld half ihnen leider nicht viel denn
genau als sie ihren scam in die wege leiteten schlug das bka zu nur durch
eine enge zusammenarbeit der strafvermittler in deutschland den
niederlanden und den usa konnten erst die server und dann die mutmaßlichen
täter identifiziert werden am 23. und 24 april 2019 haben die deutschen
ermittler die mutmaßlichen betreiber koda vor 20 kronos und the one fest
genommen sie beschlagnahmten 5 moment was hier los 20 kronos und the one warum
sind das weibliche handschellen damit bin ich nicht einverstanden
festgenommen sie beschlagnahmten 550.000 euro in bargeld bitcoin und monero in
sechsstelliger höhe und mehrere teure autos eins davon warum haben die alle
immer diese klischee autos sind mercedes amg gts tatsächlich haben die
ermittler auch heraus sollen sich alle mann opel agila 2001 kaufen da kommt
bestimmt keiner drauf dass es ein darknet dealer ist betreiber des wallstreet
markets mutmaßlich schon mal einen darknet market betrieben haben den
german plaza market auch dort haben sie im mai 2016 anscheinend einen exit scam
durchgezogen und rund 1,1 millionen euro in bitcoin erbeutet aber wie wurden sie
letztlich nach all den jahren erwischt koda vor 20 und kronos haben beide vpns
benutzt um sich mit den wallstreet market servan zu verbinden
vpn steht für virtual private network das heißt es verbinden
stimmt nord vpn oder express vpn binde dich erst mit einem bestimmten server
und dann mit dem eigentlichen ziel das macht sich im prinzip relativ anonymen
leider ist das vpn von koda vor 20 zeitweise einfach ausgefallen
das ist fett wenn es zum thema vpn angeht vpn da habe ich mal ein video
zugemacht wer sich wer sich dafür interessiert wo ich
wo ich mich mal zum thema ausgelassen habe die werbung von den vpn anbietern
und was was es hält unterm strich also wer sich interessiert ich habe da mal
20 minuten meinen gehirn dazu ausgelehrt
mit dem immer gleichen vpn server verbunden wenn er auf die server des
markets zugreifen wollte das bka hat sich den betreffenden vpn server
einfach so lange angeschaut bis klar war welche der verbindungen zu ihm führt
big brain noch der one der typ der das vorliest hat kein platzen schirm um
was es geht 2017 also knapp zwei jahre vorher haben
internationale behörden den damals größten darknet markt offline genommen
gleichzeitig haben sie den zweitgrößten markt heimlich unter ihre
kontrolle gebracht in der folge sind viele kunden und händler des größten
marktes zum zweitgrößten umgezogen und in eine riesige falle getappt auf dem
zweitgrößten markt gab es einen account namens dude bei die behörden fanden
heraus dass dude bei und the one ein und dieselbe person sind dude bei aka the one
hatte einige bitcoins die sind zwar an sich anonym aber transaktionen mit
bitcoin sind quasi öffentlich die behörden haben die bitcoin
blockchain durch das halbe internet verfolgt bis mit ihnen mit einer webde
email und klar namen ein digitaler marketing plan gekauft
ja nicht aufgepasst nicht aufgepasst aber so klein scheiß ist es im
endeffekt immer der ein zum verhängnis wird medellin der community manager hat
sich 2017 im zuge der schließung des größten marktes beim zweit kannst nicht
immer an alles denken beworben leider schrieb er unwissentlich mit der
niederländischen polizei medellin gab ihnen nach einigem hin und her als
vertrauensbeweis tatsächlich eine adresse in sao paulo brasilien angeblich die
eines bekannten es war seine eigene darknet-märkte sind beliebter denn je sie
sind bequem und versprechen anonymität der nächste kommt bestimmt besser
auf nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe
medellin der community manager hat sich 2017 im zuge der schließung des größten
marktes beim zweitgrößten beworben leider schrieb er unwissentlich mit der
niederländischen polizei medellin gab ihnen nach einigem hin und her als
vertrauensbeweis tatsächlich eine adresse in sao paulo brasilien angeblich
die eines bekannten es war seine eigene
darknet-märkte sind beliebter denn je sie sind bequem und versprechen
anonymität der nächste kommt bestimmt besser
aufgezogen als der letzte und auch die behörden werden dann mit noch klügeren
metoden vorgehen dieses katzen maus spiel wird niemals ein ende finden weil es
genug nachfrage natürlich nicht substanzen gibt und da spielt dann
eigentlich diese ganze darknet technologie einfach nur eine absolute
nebenrolle ist das darknet wegen solchen marktplätzen ein böser ort
etwas schlechtes im internet muss es orte geben die sich der überwachung
totalitärer regime entzieht hat die lust ein mx 300 auf weiß ich muss mal
gucken
also wenn dann ein neueres model das polster sieht sehr nach mx 300 aus
ich finde es sieht ein bisschen aus wie das flug wie diese flugzeug headsets die
die bei dynamics macht aber das also es sieht es sieht schon
und da spielt dann eigentlich diese ganze darknet technologie einfach nur eine
absolute nebenrolle ist das darknet wegen solchen marktplätzen ein böser
ort etwas schlechtes nein im internet muss es sagt das hat er auf der
überwachung totalitärer regime entziehen bei mx 797 hat er auf das heißt
tatsächlich so ja das hat er auf dann ist es doch das für die für für pilot
stellts
listen in die kein staatliches flutlicht scheint manchmal ist es ok wenn es
dunkel ist was ein outro wieder alle hoffentlich hat euch das video gefallen
schreibt uns eure meinung zu dem thema unbedingt in die excellent
so
Leute ich hab hunger was haben wir hier noch fire was firecracker jalapenos
peppa poppers und was war das video so schlimm nö war ganz gut excellent
um
All right, we have to thank citrus safe for sponsoring our video
We appreciate your support when cleaning your grill use some citrus safe. All right for this recipe
You're gonna need some garlic powder. You're gonna need some onion powder here. We have some cayenne pepper
We got some paprika here. Paprika cheese. We got some ground beef here
We've got some bacon. All right, you know about that, right? We've got some hot sauce
We've got some seasoning. And here's the magic. We have some jalapeno peppers
You all know about those, right?
Ein bisschen bacon, so so so 1-2 Scheiben
All right. Now we're gonna add the onion powder, the garlic powder, the paprika, the cayenne pepper
To about one pound of ground beef and use a ground chuck if you can for best taste and flavor, right?
Glaubt ihr, er kauft Bio-Fleisch? Ich glaube, dass die Bio-Fleisch kaufen, aber ohne dass da Bio drauf steht
Ich gehe mal davon aus, die kaufen wahrscheinlich bei irgendeinem Schlachtladen bei ihnen um die Ecke auf dem Land
Also wahrscheinlich ist das sogar relativ bio, was die da haben
And here we've got some seasoning
Of course, we're gonna use our SPG, at least use some salt and pepper or what you have, right?
And here we're gonna add a bit of liquid and more heat. After all, these are firecracker pepper poppers, right?
So we're gonna add a couple tablespoons of some heat
Now of course the pit master privilege of this recipe is you get to make it yourself
You can adjust the ingredients ultimately, what you want to go in this
Ein bisschen Butter, ein bisschen Butter, minimal Butter brauchen wir ja
Wobei, ist das überhaupt Butter?
Now we're gonna add a couple tablespoons of cream cheese to this
Das ist Käse? Ah, das ist Frischkäse
Now let's prepare these jalapeno peppers
And most people will go ahead and of course they'll slice it in two and they'll put it together or whatever
And they complain that the cheese oozes out during the cooking
You have to make it 100 per equal, because after every second sentence you'll make it
The knife of these never looks sharp
They also do everything with the machete
From cutting meat to cutting food to cutting trees, they do everything with the same machete
This has the heat in it, and you can keep as much or as little as you want in this recipe
And I'll show you what's next, alright?
See how easy that white membrane and all the real heat of the pepper comes out
This is really coconut music, yeah
Just in case you fell asleep
Man, this thing didn't really get it
Yeah, and you can find these apple cores pretty much anywhere
Alright, see?
Wie heisten sowas nach? Was muss ich denn da suchen?
Apfelausstecher, oder?
That's what a lot of us want
Alright, so you've seen us do that
Now we're just gonna chop up some of this little white meat
Ah, excellent
Was schauen wir und warum? Wir gucken uns grad, weil ich Hunger hab und gleich mir was zu essen mache
Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal ein Grillvideo an, dann kann ich was essen
Hast du schon dein Pitmaster-Certifikat?
Nee
Ich mach mir was zu essen, ja?
Also, Moment, Moment, um das mal zu klären
Ich mach mir was warm, was schon fertig ist
Da wird es schön reingestoft
You definitely gotta check it out
You're gonna wanna make a bunch
They'll go fast for snacking
Or if you insist
Simple enough, sagt er immer
Alright, got plenty of ground beef in there
Just keep stuffing it
Alright
You get the picture, right?
Es sieht ein bisschen eklig aus, was er da macht, wenn ich ehrlich bin
Oh man
Kind of missing it
Since this lockdown here, right?
Oh wow
Alright
It's lockdown here
Your peppers are stuffed
Now we have some ground beef mixture
War Formel 1 eigentlich schon? Keine Ahnung, ich guck keine Formel 1
Ground beef mixture here
So we're gonna make some fireball meatballs
Some mini fireball meatballs
And if you've been watching us over the last 13 years
You know all about fireball meatballs
Stopp, Veganer werden das besonders mögen hier
Okay
Now, what we wanna do
Is wrap these peppers with some bacon
Aber okay, das war noch nicht genug Fleisch, verstehe
Ordinary pork belly bacon
This is the regular cut
Excellent
You don't wanna go thick cut, right?
It takes too long to use a thick cut
Okay, okay, okay, verstehe
You know what I mean, right?
So use regular cut bacon
Das ist bacon, der quasi 90% aus Fett besteht
Now, you may get away with just using one full strip of bacon
Or you might need two
Either or
Comes out perfect
Now, let me show you again
Selbstverständlich, wir haben hier Fleisch drauf
Essentially adding another layer of flavor here
Yeah, der kann es ja nicht verkommen lassen
Rate 1 Speck
Hahaha, genau
Kokona Rate 1
And we'll take one of these fireball meatballs
And wrap it in bacon as well
Aha
Guck mal, das geht auch ohne Jalapeños
Die kannst du einfach weglassen
Du machst einfach eine Frikadelle
Und wickelst nochmal bacon drum
Also quasi Frikadelle mit bacon drum
Frikadelle mit Speckmantel
Hahaha
Oh nein
Oh nein, das geht auch ohne Jalapeños
Das sieht aber gut aus
Das sieht aber echt ganz gut aus
Ein bisschen Cheese kommt da bestimmt noch drauf
Erstmal eine Runde Barbecue Sauce einpinseln
Also ich muss sagen
Da guckt ja noch ein bisschen
Grünes durch
Und nochmal eine Runde bacon drum
Aber das kann nicht sein, dass man das noch sieht, was da drunter ist
Das geht nicht
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn da noch ein bisschen Käse am Ende drauf kommt
Boston Pinsel fürs Essen
Wir können froh sein, dass er das nicht wieder mit seiner Machete macht
Oh es regnet
Das sieht wirklich ziemlich gut aus muss ich sagen
Also ich würde es mal probieren
Also probieren würde ich das mal
Wie viel sind denn 160 Grad Fahrenheit?
Wie du kannst keine NA Einheiten im Kopf umrechnen?
Das sieht echt gut aus
Freedom Units
Are done
Kann man essen
Das ist sowas was ich nicht durchschneiden würde
Weil das innen drin jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig gut ausschaut
Am besten hier ein Stück
Weil der Bacon außen sieht viel besser aus
Einfach im Ganzen rein
Du kannst es ja abbeißen, aber ich würde es nicht zum Anrichten durchschneiden
Das ist jetzt eine Frikadelle mit Speckmantel drum herum
Excellent
Das mache ich jetzt
Also wenn ich jetzt das Zeug da hätte dafür
Würde ich mir das tatsächlich jetzt mal gönnen
Das sah echt gut aus
Ich hab Hunger
Ich hab richtig Hunger
Der Drecks Kanal ist am Start
Wusste nicht mal, dass du Streams vermisse deine YouTube Videos
Ja YouTube Videos
Ja
Pepehands
Es wird mal wieder Zeit für YouTube Videos
Korrekt
Aber irgendwie habe ich da gerade keinen großartigen Hang dazu YouTube Videos zu machen
Was machst du dir jetzt warm?
Bandnudeln mit Lachs
Vielleicht, mal gucken
Ob dann auch genug da ist
Bandnudeln mit Lachs
Oder
Weiß nicht, mal schauen
Mal gucken
Wenn ich gar nichts finde, bestelle ich mir irgendwas
Wie läuft alles gut?
Jo, jo alles, alles top
Ich bin ja fast jeden Tag mittlerweile hier auf Twitch
Irgendwie finde ich das viel entspannter
Was für Band?
Bandnudel
Bandnudel mit Lachs
Ne, nichts tief gekühltes, fertig Sauce
Ja, vielleicht bestelle ich mir auch was.
Ah gucken, weiß ich nicht genau.
Muss ich mal, muss ich mal schauen, erstmal gucke ich ob noch was da ist von gestern.
Ja Leute, bei Herz93 gibt es heute Spagetti Pizza, okay man kann auf Pizza alles drauf
machen.
Meine persönliche Lieblingspizza, die absolut unitalienisch ist, ist Pizza mit Soß Hollandaise,
Pizza mit Bacon und Soß Hollandaise drauf.
Ist absolut unitalienisch, ich weiß, aber das schmeckt extrem gut.
Soß Hollandaise, genau, mit Pizza Bacon.
Ich faken Bacon, ah exzellent, aber nicht, aber keine Tiefkühl, keine Tiefkühlpizza.
So was hier, Bacon, Zwiebel, Soß Hollandaise, super Pizza, richtig geil.
Perky, Agnostic, Pizza, Soße, Soß Hollandaise, Brokkoli und Chicken ist auch gut.
Gibt es paar Varianten, die auch ganz gut sind, ja.
Ne, Mayonnaise esse ich nicht so gern.
Da wirst du eh teilweise gebated.
Ich habe letztens gesehen im EDK irgendwie Tomy Pommes Soße und das war halt einfach
Mayonnaise.
Mayonnaise selbst hat wohl so einen schlechten Ruf mittlerweile, deswegen nennt man das Pommes
Soße, obwohl es einfach stinknormale Mayonnaise ist.
Schinken, Brokkoli, Soß Hollandaise, ja, geht alles, also meine Lieblingskombination
ist wirklich sowas hier, Bacon, Zwiebel, Soß Hollandaise, ist wirklich hier, was auch
noch ganz gut ist, Pepperoniwurst drauf.
Excellent, Felix sagt hallo, drei Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Jetzt kommt das Scamtrain, jetzt wo ich aufgehen will kommt das Scamtrain, was ist denn eine
Pepperoniwurst, so eine kleine Salami, sowas da, so eine kleine Salami, ich weiß gar nicht
ob man das wirklich Pepperoniwurst nennt.
Einfach essen, bestellen, weiter streamen, ey ich mach mir jetzt was zu essen.
Machst du Pizza selber, hast du so einen Stein, nö, dafür gibt es hier so viele Lieferservices,
das ist echt nicht mehr feierlich, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, so vor, also ich
wohne ja nicht mitten in Frankfurt, ich arbeite in Frankfurt, ich wohne auch ziemlich nahe
an Frankfurt, aber ich wohne nicht mitten in Frankfurt und diese ganze Lieferservice
Geschichte ist bei uns erst so richtig geboomt, als Pizza.de Lieferando Lieferheld und das
ganze Zeug angefangen hat und das ist jetzt ja auch schon 10 Jahre her und mittlerweile
gibt es hier so viele Lieferdienste, du kannst jeden Tag was anderes bestellen und brauchst
einen Monat bis du alles durch hast, so nach dem Motto, noch nicht mal, ein halbes Jahr
bist du alles durch, es gibt so viele mittlerweile, aber ich bestelle immer nur bei 5, 6 verschiedenen
Lieferservices, also am liebsten bestelle ich in letzter Zeit bei so einem Laden, das
ist eigentlich laut Namen her was italienisches, aber die haben alles mögliche, vom Schnitzel
mit Rahmsoße bis zu Pizza, im Prinzip, ja doch, alles mögliche haben die nicht, die
haben kein Döner, kein Indisch und so, die haben eigentlich nur italienisches Zeug und
die sind gar nicht so weit weg von mir und letztens bin ich an dem Laden vorbeigefahren
und ich dachte bisher immer, das sind Italiener, weil die haben auch einen sehr italienischen
Namen, also geht mal davon, ich sag jetzt nicht den Namen, weil der ist relativ außergewöhnlich
denke ich, aber es ist so was in der Richtung, wie wenn das Ding Bella Italia heißt, ja,
so heißt auch jede dritte Pizzeria, aber es gibt es halt nicht so oft den Namen hier
und dann bin ich letztens mal dran vorbei an dem Laden und ich dachte halt, das sind
Italiener und dann bin ich dran vorbei gefahren und da läuft irgendwelche arabische Musik
da und da eine Typ ist da mitsingen, okay, das hat sich jetzt alles andere als italienisch
angehört, dafür machen sie gut das Essen, also mir ist ehrlich gesagt scheißegal wo
die herkommen, so lange das Essen schmeckt, aber das ist alles die Homepage der Name
und es ist alles voll italienisch aufgezogen und wenn du dann auf die Homepage gehst, ich
glaube da stellst du fest, okay, die kommen hier aus Pakistan oder so, hat mit italienisch
überhaupt nichts zu tun, ist halt nur gut auf italienisch gemacht, hast du eigentlich
ein Auto, ja, ich hab ein Opel Agila 2001, ja gut, mein Pizzeria, ganz ehrlich ich kann
es verstehen, eine Pizzeria verkauft sich ja auch besser, wenn es auf italienisch gemacht
ist, wie wenn das einen pakistanischen Namen hätte, das war kein Scherz mit dem Auto,
das war ernst gemeint, ich hab ne Mercedes aus 2020, wer hat der hat ne, nö ich seh
auch keinen Grund mehr neues Auto zu kaufen, aktuell ist eh Dauer Homeoffice, ich hab ne
Jahreskarte für, also Jahresticket für Bahn, öffentliche Verkehrsmittel, was in ganz Hessen
gilt und für die Fälle wo man ein Auto braucht tut es der Opel Agila auch, Auto liegt, ja
in grün, auch noch in grün, Agila 2001 in grün, wenn du selbstständig bist brauchst
du ein Auto und Gewerbeleasing ist lächerlich was die Preise angeht, meinst du mit lächerlich
jetzt günstig oder zu teuer, ich hab mir das tatsächlich auch schonmal überlegt mit Auto
leasen, ich hab ja ne eigene Firma, weiß nicht ob man da, was der Mindestumsatz ist
dass man da Autos leasen darf, günstig ist fuck ok, der Hype Train, du hast den Hype
Train verpasst Leute, feels Batman, schau mal mydeals.de, ich guck öfters mydeals.de aber
ich guck da ehrlich gesagt immer nur nach irgendwelcher China Hardware, was kostet so
eine RMV Jahreskarte, oh das kann ich dir nicht sagen, die ist gesponsort, ja sie ist
subventioniert, ich muss sie nicht komplett bezahlen, boah keine Ahnung, fahr ich jetzt
aus dem Kopf nicht, Geld, was du bezahlst 210€ im Monat mit der Werkstatt alles inklusive,
das Auto kostet 90k, oh das geht, das ist doch wirklich nicht verkehrt, aber da ist
bestimmt auch irgendein Haken dabei, also so nach dem Motto, du musst mindestens so und
so viel machen und das kostet extra oder irgendwas, Max FPS GmbH, ne ne, ich mein das geht doch
210€ im Monat für ein Auto was 99k kostet, das klingt jetzt erstmal recht sinnig ja,
gut aber davon abgesehen, ich brauch auch kein 90k Auto, so, also Leute ich geh jetzt
essen, was ist denn das für ein hässlicher Schuh, ah Kletterschuh ok, alles gut na dann,
ja aber das hört sich nicht verkehrt an, braucht man irgendeinen gewissen Mindestumsatz
oder so, dass man das machen kann oder braucht man einfach nur ein Gewerbezettel, weil wenn
es danach geht, könnte ich das ja theoretisch auch machen, kein Plan, mal gucken aber wie
ist das, ich brauch hier kein Auto, Gartenställz mit grünem Lambo, exakt, genau, komm in die
Gruppe, so Leute ich geh jetzt was essen, also wir sehen uns, bis dann machts gut, c u.